Politikwissenschaftlerin Julia
Reuschenbach von dem otto-suhr-institut
hier in Berlin Frau Reuschenbach die CDU
hat ja einen großen Prozess eingeleitet
war es für die CDU nach dieser
Wahlniederlage vor zwei Jahren dringend
notwendig ein neues Grundsatzprogramm zu
schreiben ja mit Sicherheit war es das
das letzte Grundsatzprogramm liegt lange
zurück die Welt hat sich verändert die
Themen haben sich verändert insbesondere
die Krisenhaftigkeit und auf solche
Phänomene muss natürlich eine
Volkspartei wie die CDU Antworten finden
und wir haben nicht ohne Grund darüber
gesprochen dass unter Angela Merkel die
Partei sehr stark sich hinter der
Kanzlerin versammelt aber weniger
programmatisch an sich selbst gearbeitet
hat insofern war erwartbar insbesondere
mit der Herren Niederlage 2021 dass man
diesen Prozess jetzt noch mal aufnimmt
und wirklich auch intensiv über einen
sehr langen Zeitraum hier in der Partei
betreibt der relativ neue
Parteivorsitzende Friedrich Merz Ring
darum die Partei hinter sich zu bringen
das ist nicht einfach viele die von ihm
an konservativen Kurs erwartet haben
sind enttäuscht weil er auch auf die
anderen Rücksicht nehmen muss wo ist da
die Lösung ja wahrscheinlich
liegt über die Wahrheit in dem Fall auch
in der Mitte denn genau das
Zeichen ja hätte man gesagt dass
merkelager symbolisiert die sich noch
mal eine Weiterentwicklung wollen
wünschen eine Öffnung zu neuen
Wählergruppen beispielsweise sie haben
diese Woche etwa den Vorschlag gehört
von Hendrik wüst die CDU müsste auch die
Partei der allein erziehenden werden und
dann gibt es eben das von Ihnen
beschriebene Lager die sich eine härtere
Gangart wünschen rigidere Positionen
etwa auch in der Migrationspolitik und
die Aufgabe eines jeden
Parteivorsitzenden ist es natürlich
diese Strömungen in einer Partei
zusammenzuführen ich würde sagen es ist
nicht nur das sich hinter sich
versammeln sondern wirklich eine
Selbstvergewisserung wofür steht die CDU
im Jahr 2023 und was sind auch die
Erwartungen die ein Friedrich Merz an
sich und an seine Partei hat wenn wir
etwa mal daran denken dass er ja mal
angetreten ist nicht nur mit dem Wunsch
an die 30 sondern über die 30% zu kommen
mit der Partei oder etwa auch mit der
Idee man könne womöglich die AFD
halbieren da bleiben sozusagen Fragen
offen und ich glaube deswegen ist dieser
programmatische Prozess umso wichtiger
um da eine gemeinsame Position Frauen in
der Partei zu entwickeln naja von dem
halbieren der hatte sich schon seit
Jahren distanziert das hat er 2019 ganz
am Anfang des Jahres mal gesagt aber
gestern hat er ja bei dem kleinen
Parteitag noch mal klar gemacht und das
hat er auch schon seitdem er Parteichef
ist mit der AFD wird es keinerlei
Zusammenarbeit geben das ist auch nicht
einfach für die CDU denn die natürlichen
Koalitionspartner gehen ihn so langsam
aus der Brust über die Grünen ist hier
der CDU deutlich zu spüren
über Jahre so als die Koalition der
Zukunft galt irgendwie in schwieriges
fahrwassergerät obwohl wir gleichzeitig
sehen dass in Bundesländern wie
Nordrhein-Westfalen oder
Schleswig-Holstein die Parteien sehr
erfolgreich miteinander regieren
koalieren und ja das Verhältnis zu AFD
ist geklärt es gibt die viel beschworene
Brandmauer es gibt immer wieder die
klaren Statements von Friedrich Merz der
eine Zusammenarbeit ausschließt aber wir
wissen eben auch es gibt die Stimmen
zumindest auf der kommunalen Ebene die
das anders sehen wir haben eine sehr
scharfe Rhetorik gesehen Begriffe wie
klimadiktatur sind gefallen etwa durch
Jens Spahn auf dem Deutschland Tag der
Jungen Union und natürlich muss man sich
fragen lassen wenn man solche Begriffe
verwendet was sagt das aus was ist unser
programmatisches Profil und man wird
sich fragen lassen müssen wenn man etwa
in gender Fragen und in anderen Themen
mit der AFD so dicht beieinander liegt
warum dann gleichzeitig die
Zusammenarbeit nicht möglich sein soll
insofern ich glaube daran darf man
keinen Zweifel haben dass diese Position
da ist und dass sie standhaft ist aber
umso wichtiger dass die Partei wirklich
über ihre Programmatik jetzt diskutiert
und eine Idee davon entwirft was
Konservatismus im Jahr 2023 sein soll
Hendrik wüst hat sozusagen den Wahlkampf
eröffnet der hat nämlich gesagt die CDU
muss eine Partei der Mitte sein die
Landesverbände müssen mitreden das haben
viele der so interpretiert dass er
seinen Hut in den Ring geworfen hat und
für dich März hat gestern auch schon
reagiert auf dem kleinen Parteitag er
hat das allererste Mal Frau Merkel im
Zusammenhang mit den großen Kanzlern
Adenauer und Kohl und Merkel genannt das
haben viele sehr hohen registriert ist
das dieser Kampf der die CDU die
nächsten anderthalb Jahre begleiten wird
naja bestenfalls wird es gar kein Kampf
die Partei hat ja gerade bei der
Kanzlerkandidatur 2021 erlebt wie
schwierig solche personalpolitischen
Debatten auf Dauer sein können es wird
vielmehr um die Frage gehen ist die CDU
der Zukunft eine in der beide Positionen
Platz finden in der man nebeneinander
und miteinander arbeiten kann insofern
vielleicht ja ein Hauch von
Kanzlerkandidatur Wahlkampfauftakt mit
diesem Gastbeitrag von Hendrik wüst aber
vor allen Dingen das Signal dass die
Partei sich auch diesen Fragen stellen
muss und die Politikwissenschaft
beispielsweise hat dazu eben auch ihre
Antworten dass etwa das an dienen an
rechtspopulistische Sprache eben nicht
einzahlt auf das Konto konservativer
Parteien sondern vor allen Dingen auf
dass der originale also der
Rechtspopulisten und auch das Wahlen in
Deutschland in der Mitte gewonnen werden
da das größte Wählerpotential liegt das
können wir unterschreiben insofern ist
es gut dass die Debatte jetzt
stattfindet heute auf dem Konvent kommen
auch Menschen zu Wort die nicht in der
CDU sind Verbände vom Sport
Gewerkschaften
dieser Prozess ist ja doch sehr
aufwendig den die CDU hier gegangen ist
Carsten Lindemann gesagt es ist
notwendig dass wir ein neues Programm
machen und selbst wieder orientieren
helmut Kohl hat damals das Programm so
ausgerichtet dass das allererste Mal die
CDU in den 70 Jahren zum Mitglieder
Partei wurde was muss man am Ende in
einem Jahr hier abliefern welche
Richtung sollte Ihrer Meinung nach so
ein Programm gehen
vor allen Dingen muss es über zeitlich
sein es muss Antworten haben auf die
großen Fragen der Zukunft wir sehen in
den Umfragen immer wieder dass die
Menschen zweifeln an der
Problemlösungsfähigkeit der Parteien
dass sie also sagen die Parteien haben
keine Antworten auf die großen
Herausforderungen der Gegenwart und dazu
muss ein Programm Antworten liefern also
nicht im kleinen kleinen verharren
sondern wirklich die langen Linien die
im Grunde die Idee die vielleicht könnte
man es jetzt ein bisschen SPD angelehnt
mit der Division eines eine künftigen
CDU müsste dieses Programm skizzieren
und natürlich haben sie völlig recht
damit der Prozess ist sehr aufwendig ist
vor allen Dingen auch sehr lang sie
haben es angesprochen erst in einem Jahr
soll das Programm dann vorgestellt
werden das lässt natürlich auch viel
Raum in dem die Parteien noch bringt und
hat er den andere füllen können insofern
bin ich etwas überrascht dass man den
Zeitplan so großzügig gestaltet hat aber
umso wichtiger im nächsten Jahr stehen
wichtige Wahlen an mit der Europawahl
aber auch mit drei ostdeutschen
Landtagswahlen dass man dann im Frühjahr
für die Wahl vor allen Dingen Wahlen im
Herbst in Ostdeutschland tatsächlich
Antworten hat auf die Frage die viele
Wählerinnen und Wähler in den letzten
Jahren nicht mehr ausreichend
beantworten konnten nämlich wofür steht
denn die CDU da hat Carsten Linnemann im
Vorfeld angekündigt er möchte ganz am
Ende dieses Prozesses in einem Jahr
neben dem Grundsatzprogramm zwei Seiten
Zusammenfassungen liefern wo dann in
zehn Punkten drauf steht wofür die CDU
steht das ist in der Tat wenn man mit
Christdemokraten spricht oft gar nicht
so einfach das war aber dann immer aus
hat es die CDU als letzte verbliebene
große Volkspartei schwerer als zum
Beispiel eine Partei die Grünen die sich
immer über dieses Thema Klima und Umwelt
definiert haben ja natürlich
im Grunde von dem Begriff der
Volkspartei auch innewohnt also
unterschiedliche gesellschaftliche
Gruppen und deren Interessen
zusammenzubinden Kompromisse zu finden
wirklich die Partei als Ort zu verstehen
an dem um solche Kompromisse gerungen
wird das erfordert auf ganz vielen
Politikfeldern die Debatte den Diskurs
und die Partei wird eben anders als die
Grünen nicht nur mit einem Thema
verbunden sondern mit Wirtschaft mit
Stabilität wir haben gesehen dass es
hohe kompetenzverluste gab bei vielen
der letzten Landtagswahlen etwa im
Bereich soziale Gerechtigkeit und darauf
wird man Antworten geben müssen aber in
der Tat natürlich ist das für eine
solche Partei eine sehr große
Herausforderung wenngleich ich umgekehrt
sagen würde aus Sicht derjenigen die auf
Parteien schauen dass es auch die Grünen
vor großen Herausforderungen stehen
andere Art aber das sehen wir ja auch
zum Beispiel an der Debatte die gerade
bei den Grünen etwas zum Asylrecht
stattfindet die Grünen das kann ich den
Zuschauern noch sagen die haben heute
den kleinen Länderrat also den kleinen
Parteitag so heißt es und ähm das werden
wir ihn gleich übertragen ab 11 Uhr
die Grünen sind Teil der Ampel und
Friedrich Merz hat jetzt nicht als
einziger in diesem Land gesagt die Ampel
regiert derart katastrophal wir leben es
gerade beim heizungsgesetz dass er
eventuell der Meinung ist dass das gar
nicht bis zum Ende der Legislaturperiode
trägt einen Satz den er gestern übrigens
auf dem kleinen Parteitag so nicht
wiederholt hat aber sie als
Politikwissenschaftlerin glauben Sie
dass die Performance sie die Ampel da
hinlegt auch das Handwerk reichen wird
um das Ende der Legislaturperiode zu
erreichen aber alle drei Partner in der
Ampel haben ein ganz hohes Interesse
daran dieses Bündnis erfolgreich bis zum
Ende der Legislaturperiode vorzusetzen
insofern halte ich es für extrem
unwahrscheinlich dass wir tatsächlich
mit Neuwahlen oder einem Bruch der
Koalition rechnen müssen aber was
spannend ist und was im Raum stehen
bleiben wird sind eben die großen
schwierigen Diskussionen die diese Ampel
schon seit anderthalb Jahren für die
werden nicht weniger werdende treffen
insbesondere zwischen Grünen und FDP im
fundamental unterschiedliche
Vorstellungen aufeinander von der Rolle
startest also wie viel Eingriff soll der
Staat in unterschiedlichen Feldern
betreiben das haben wir gerade beim
Gebäude Energiegesetz ganz deutlich
gesehen Finanzen waren immer ein großes
Thema und das wird uns erhalten bleiben
insofern wird es für die Koalition
sicherlich vor allen Dingen darum gehen
ob man am Stil am Miteinander was ändern
kann einer einer besseren Kommunikation
das hat extrem gelitten in den letzten
Monaten und auch daran zu sagen gelingt
es uns nachhaltig mit einer Stimme zu
sprechen und nicht das einer der Partner
innerhalb teilweise konnte man sagen
leider weniger Stunden gemeinsam
getroffene Entscheidungen dann wieder in
Frage stellt das ist ein Bild von
Unsicherheit von Uneinigkeit dass da
gezeigt wurde und dass irritiert und
verunsichert natürlich insbesondere
beginnen und Bürger vielen Dank Frau
reuschen machen ob es die CDU an der
Regierung besser machen würde da sind
sich die Bürger nicht so ganz sicher
jedenfalls gewinnt die AFD dazu die CDU
bleibt stagniert unter den 30% und mein
Kollege sagt ihm jetzt mal ganz schnell
wie es hier weitergeht
wir sehen jetzt dass der erste Redner
abends Rednerpult getreten ist dass es
Mario Chaya der Generalsekretär und der
wird diese Veranstaltung jetzt eröffnen
mit einem Gedenken an den 70 jahrestag
des Volksaufstands in der DDR am 17 Juni
Grundsatz Konvent auf der Reise hin zu
unserem Grundsatzprogramm dem vierten
Grundsatzprogramm den zweiten in der
Opposition und vor allem dem mit 100%
CDU herzlich willkommen bei diesem
grundsatzkonvent
ich heiße ganz besonders willkommen
unseren Parteivorsitzenden dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der CDU
csu-bundestagsfraktion lieber Friedrich
Merz herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
und ein ebenso herzliches Willkommen dem
Vorsitzenden der Programm und
grundsatzkommission der stefan hat eine
Parteivorsitzende der hier so ziemlich
alles abgenommen hat noch mal in den
letzten Tagen und Stunden Karsten
herzlich willkommen du hast ein
großartigen Prozess für dieses
Grundsatzprogramm schon auf den Weg
gebracht zusammen mit seraphüller mit
Mario Vogt all den Vorsitzender
Fachkommissionen danke schön für deine
Arbeit und ein herzliches Willkommen
begrüße ganz herzlich die
stellvertretende Generalsekretärin die
nachher durch die Diskussion führen wird
wenn wir mit den Fachleuten sprechen
liebe Christina herzlich willkommen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen aus dem
Deutschen Bundestag aus den Landtagen
aus den Landesregierungen liebe
Mitglieder liebe Freunde Liebe
Unterstützer liebe Experten ein ebenso
herzliches Willkommen und ein besonderer
Gruß heute am Tag der Bundeswehr an
Generalmajor ade Bernhard Lichtenauer
schön dass Sie da sind die CDU steht an
der Seite der Soldatinnen und Soldaten
danke dass Sie da sind
heute ist der 17 Juni
heute ist der 70 jahrestag des
Volksaufstands in der DDR
vor 70 Jahren haben Frauen und Männer in
der DDR auf die haben sich auf die
Straße gewagt haben gekämpft im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes gekämpft mit bloßen
Händen gegen sowjetische Panzer
Menschen sind gestorben für die Freiheit
wir alle haben die Bilder im Kopf die
Schwarz-Weiß-Fotos dieses Volksaufstands
und sie berühren uns alle sie berühren
auch mich bis heute
bis 1990 war dieser Tag ein Symbol der
Teilung zwischen Ost und West bei uns im
Osten einen verheimlichter Tag
tabuisiert totgeschwiegen im Westen der
Tag der Deutschen Einheit
nicht alle haben ihn immer gefeiert die
Christdemokraten schon
70 Jahre später
findet der grundsatzkonvent der CDU
Deutschlands statt ich finde wir hätten
keinen besseren Tag finden können als
den heutigen den 17 Juni denn die CDU
hat in ihrer langen Geschichte schon
drei Grundsatzprogramme arbeitet in drei
verschiedenen Epochen drei verschiedene
Titel aber ein Wort
war immer dabei
Freiheit
Solidarität Gerechtigkeit
1994 Freiheit in Verantwortung
2007 Freiheit und Sicherheit
und nun ist es so meine Damen und Herren
ein Grundsatzprogramm schreibt man ja
nicht einfach so sondern man schreibt es
wenn sich grundsätzliche Dinge verändern
1978 war es die Ölkrise der Terrorismus
Inflation Arbeitslosigkeit
1994 nach dem Zusammenbruch des
Kommunismus die Wiedervereinigung die
neue Weltordnung nicht zuletzt die
drängenden Fragen von Natur und Umwelt
die 1994 eine Rolle spielten und so war
es auch 2007
Globalisierung
Wissensgesellschaft demografischer
Wandel europäische Integration aber auch
die Antworten auf den neuen
internationalen Terror der Jahre davor
und so ist es auch heute
ein mörderischer Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine
Chinas macht Hunger
Systemkonkurrenz hohe Energiepreise
Inflation wirtschaftliche Rezessionen
menschengemachter Klimawandel
gesellschaftliche Spannungen zerkräfte
die auseinander reißen und wenn sich die
Dinge grundlegend ändern wenn sich die
Dinge grundlegend verändern wächst die
Verunsicherung und es braucht eine neue
Orientierung wer könnte nicht diese neue
Orientierung geben wenn nicht wir die
Christdemokraten die politische Kraft
die in 50 von 70 Jahren in unserem Land
Verantwortung hatte keine andere Partei
hat dieses Land in den großen Krisen und
den großen Herausforderungen so geprägt
wie wir das ist der Anspruch den wir an
unser Grundsatzprogramm haben in dieser
Zeit Ordnung Sicherheitsstruktur Leid
Flanken zu geben und Sicherheit zu geben
dass wir die Menschen dass wir dieses
Land gut durch die Zeit führen
nun kennen wir noch nicht den Titel
unseres vierten Grundsatzprogramms ich
glaube selbst Carsten kennt die noch
nicht
aber wir kennen die Eckpunkte und wir
wissen ganz sicher Freiheit wird eine
große Rolle spielen
wenn für unsere Partei ist Freiheit
nicht irgendein Wert
wir wissen
dass es immer wieder Bedrohung der
Freiheit gibt im äußeren im Inneren
und das Streben nach Freiheit wir haben
es gestern Abend noch mal bei der
Konrad-Adenauer-Stiftung in so
beeindruckender Weise vernommen
das Streben nach Freiheit wohnt uns
Menschen inne Freiheit ist tief in
unseren Herzen und Köpfen verwurzelt und
muss als kostbares Gut bewahrt geschützt
und im Zweifel auch verteidigt werden
und im Europa der Nachkriegszeit war
Freiheit keine Selbstverständlichkeit es
gab die verschiedensten Formen des
Widerstandes wie etwa dem Volksaufstand
in der DDR 1953 nur heute beginnt aber
danach die ungarische Revolution 1956
der Prager Frühling 68 die
solidarnerbewegung in Polen in den 80er
Jahren und so war für manche das Jahr
1953 scheinbar ein vergeblicher Versuch
um Freiheit zu kämpfen aber der Versuch
war nicht umsonst 36 Jahre später
1989 im zweiten großen Anlauf haben sich
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger der DDR die
Freiheit friedlich errungen diese
Menschen haben einen brutales System
gestürzt sie haben eine Diktatur in die
Knie gezwungen sie sind über sich hinaus
gewachsen
das ist eine Erfahrung eine historische
Leistung
die dem Selbstbild Ostdeutschlands immer
wieder entspricht die zum Selbstbild
Ostdeutschlands dazugehört und ich muss
Ihnen sagen umso schmerzlicher und
bedrückender ist es was wir heute auch
im Osten in manchen Fragen im Besonderen
im Osten sehen wo Linksaußen und rechts
außen
zusammenkommen und brüllen und manchmal
hat man irgendwie den Wunsch die
Menschen zu schütteln und zu fragen hast
du ganz vergessen wofür wir
1989 auf die Straße gegangen sind und
wogegen wir wollen freie Menschen sein
das war die Parole des 17 Juni 1953 und
am 4 september 1989 hielten die Menschen
in Leipzig ein Plakat hoch auf dem Stand
für ein offenes Land mit freien Menschen
wer die Freiheit will läuft den nicht
hinterher die die Freiheit bekämpfen wer
die Freiheit will muss diejenigen auch
bekämpfen die die Freiheit immer wieder
in Frage stellen und deswegen ist es so
wichtig dass wir für die Freiheit
eintreten wir zum Ausdruck bringen dass
wir uns auch abgrenzen von denen die
Freiheit jeden Tag aufs Neue infrage
stellen
wenn wer die Freiheit will der tritt
einen für Pressefreiheit für
Meinungsfreiheit wer die Freiheit will
tritt einen für Demokratie und
Rechtsstaat
wer die Freiheit will tritt ein für ein
offenes Land mit freien Menschen
aber gleichzeitig muss eine Partei der
Freiheit auch dafür arbeiten dass
Menschen nicht das Gefühl haben das Land
lebt ohne mich das Land lebt über mich
das Land lebt an mir vorbei
eine Partei der Freiheit sorgt für
Zugehörigkeit
für Zusammenhalt
eine Partei sorgt für
Chancengerechtigkeit sie sorgt dafür
dass die grundlegenden Dinge des Lebens
in unserem Land funktionieren dass man
ein Arzt findet wenn man ihn braucht
dass man auf der Straße sicher ist dass
man gut von A nach B kommt dass man eine
Arbeit und eine Rente hat und man davon
anständig Leben und alt werden kann ohne
Hilfe des Staates zu brauchen
dass man dazu gehört egal wo man seine
Heimat hat oder wo man seiner Heimat
hatte
und wir nehmen uns heute die Freiheit
die Freiheit im Denken
die Freiheit für ihre Gedanken für ihre
Ideen für Ihre Meinung wir sind als
Parteiführung unter Friedrich Merz mit
dem Anspruch angetreten die CDU zu
öffnen Sie programmatisch
weiterzuentwickeln und zukunftstauglich
zu machen wir machen die Fenster und
Türen auf für Lüften durch so wie es
Helmut Kohl mit hans-biedenkopf und
Heiner Geißler
damals getan hat als 1976 der erste
grundsatzkonvent der Partei
stattgefunden haben sie öffneten die
Partei und machten sie zur
Mitgliederpartei 200.000 Menschen sind
damals in die CDU eingetreten und das
nur in Westdeutschland Karin auch
wir machen die CDU zur Mitmachpartei und
deshalb freuen wir uns dass Sie heute
mitmachen herzlichen Dank dass Sie sich
aufgemacht haben hierher zu kommen dass
Sie uns Ihre Ideen ihre Gedanken ihre
Inspiration für unser Land mithelfen in
unser Programm zu schreiben dafür schon
an dieser Stelle ein herzliches
Dankeschön
los geht's gleich mit Kasten Linnemann
der uns mit auf den Weg zum neuen
Grundsatzprogramm nimmt
danach empfängt Kristina stumpf 5
herausragende Gäste aus den wichtigen
Bereichen der Zivilgesellschaft
wir freuen uns darauf zu hören was uns
Tanja Gönner die Hauptgeschäftsführerin
des BDI aus Sicht der Wirtschaft zu
sagen hat ein herzliches Willkommen
wir freuen uns darüber dass Michael was
sie da ist da ist ein herzliches bekommt
der Präsident des Europäischen Verbundes
der
Industriegewerkschaften und als
Vorsitzender der Gewerkschaft
IG BAU Chemie und Energie herzlichen
Dank dass Sie heute den
wir haben Eva Maria welzkopf de vorbei
uns die für den großen Sozialverband
Caritas da ist und damit für die großen
Wohlfahrtsorganisation spricht für
gelebte Subsidiarität wie wir sie in
unserem Land verstehen ein herzliches
Willkommen
und es ist uns eine besondere Ehre dass
Claudia Pechstein für das Thema Sport
und Ehrenamt bei uns ist sie hat mit
ihrer Biografie gezeigt wie ein
Zusammenwachsen der deutschen
Gesellschaft der deutschen Bevölkerung
nach der deutschen Teilung über den
Sport funktionieren kann und damit
welchen wichtigen Zusammenhalt Sport für
die Gesellschaft geben kann liebe
Claudia herzlich willkommen
und ich freue mich dass ein Vertreter
der jüngsten deutschen Politik
Podcaster Generation da ist für die
Stimme der jungen Generation ist bei uns
Ruben Giuliano herzlich willkommen
viel Spannung verspricht auch denen die
uns zuschauen
nachher die Debatte zwischen dem vor
unserem Vorsitzenden Friedrich Merz und
Ralf Fuchs dem Direktor der
denkwerkstattzentrum liberale moderne
sie sprechen gemeinsam darüber was ist
eigentlich grundsätzlich CDU auch Ihnen
Herr Füchs ein ganz herzliches
Willkommen bei uns bei den
Christdemokraten
und danach öffnen wir im wahrsten Sinne
des Wortes die Türen
wir haben bei diesem Grundsatz kommt
Konvent vor dass danach in den konkreten
Themen sie in den Fachkommissionen mit
den Vorsitzenden der Fachkommission
Arbeiten es gibt fünf parallele Foren
vor der Mittagspause und fünf danach wir
haben Fachleute aus allen Bereichen
eingeladen aus Wissenschaft und
Forschung aus der Wirtschaft von vielen
Verbänden die heute da sind die
miteinander reden und Ihre Fragen
beantworten
suchen Sie sich frei ein Thema aus und
diskutieren Sie mit uns
liebe Freundinnen und Freunde ein
Grundsatzprogramm ist viel mehr als ein
Wahlprogramm
es muss auf der Geschichte aufbauen und
ein Bild von der Zukunft entwerfen
es muss unverwechselbar
christdemokratisch sein und zugleich
eine Einladung aussprechen die uns an
all jene die unsere Werte teilen
wir wollen politische Heimat sein für
alle Menschen in Deutschland egal an was
sie glauben egal wo sie herkommen egal
wen sie lieben vorausgesetzt sie teilen
unsere Werte
ein Grundsatzprogramm ist eine
Festlegung ja aber keine Fessel
stellen sich also jetzt ein Bücherregal
vor drei Bände mit den Grundsätzen und
Werten stehen da schon drin ein vierter
Band kommt bald spätestens im Mai nach
unserem Parteitag hinzu
auch als eBook
es reiht sich ein in die ersten drei und
ist trotzdem unterscheidbar und da ich
gerade von unserem Bild der Zukunft
spreche links von der Bühne werden wir
nachher sie sehen es schon Frau Dr
Franziska schwarz
ein Bild von dem haben was unser
Grundsatzprogramm ausmacht sie trägt
unsere Gedanken unsere Ideen unsere
Ergebnisse in einem großen Bild zusammen
und zum Ende der Veranstaltung sehen wir
dann das Ergebnis dann haben wir
vielleicht schon eine kleine Ahnung
davon wie das Zukunftsbild der
christlich-demokratischen Union aussieht
herzlich willkommen liebe Frau Dr
schwarz schön dass Sie da sind
und wo wir stehen in unserem
grundsatzprogrammprozess
das zeigen wir jetzt gleich noch in
einem kurzen Video und dann hast du
lieber Carsten das Wort herzlich
willkommen ein zusammen uns ein richtig
guten Tag hier
[Applaus]
Mario Czaja war das der Generalsekretär
der CDU mit einem kurzen erinnern an den
Volksaufstand in der DDR am 17 Juni
noch viel mehr aber mit Erläuterungen zu
denen was heute hier passiert in Berlin
die CDU arbeitet an einem neuen
Grundsatzprogramm der Grundsatz Convent
so ist die Veranstaltung heute
überschrieben Mario ciao hat einen
weiten Bogen geschlagen gerade zum Thema
Freiheit auch Freiheit auch für die
Menschen beim Volksaufstand auf die
Straße gegangen sind in der DDR am 17
Juni 1953 und Freiheit das immer wieder
auch ein Wort gewesen ist dass in den
Titeln der bisherigen Grundsatzprogramme
der CDU aufgetaucht ist
Freiheit Ordnung Sicherheit Struktur
Leitplanken das sei es was die Menschen
in Deutschland bräuchten hat Mario Czaja
gesagt die Dinge veränderten sich auf
dieser Welt wie kann Orientierung
geschafft werden für die Menschen wie
kann das eine Partei wie die CDU
schaffen dafür sind die Delegierten und
die Gäste heute hier zusammengekommen
Mario Czaja hat seine Partei die CDU
eine Partei der Freiheit genannt es
müsste aber auch das hat er ganz offen
auch so angesprochen mal durchgelüftet
werden in dieser Partei wie das immer
wieder in bestimmten Abständen in
solchen Parteien mal passieren muss die
CDU will sich dieses neue
Grundsatzprogramm geben die Partei
verfolgt dafür einen ambitionierten
Zeitplan bis Mitte des kommenden Jahres
soll das Grundsatzprogramm dann fertig
sein und dann will die Partei angreifen
nicht zuletzt mit Blick auf die nächste
Bundestagswahl
Opposition diese Rolle passt der Union
überhaupt nicht die Union möchte wieder
an die Regierung und dieses
Grundsatzprogramm soll dafür die
Grundlage schaffen soll dafür die
Grundlage sein um eine möglichst breite
Wählerinnen und Wähler schicken
anzusprechen
aber jetzt geht's gerade wird hier noch
ein Film gezeigt der ein bisschen den
Weg zu diesem Grundsatzprogramm
nachzeichnet nachzeichnen soll
gleich kommt dann Carsten Linnemann auf
die Bühne Carsten Linnemann das ist der
Mann in der CDU der sozusagen der Vater
ein bisschen dieses neuen
Grundsatzprogramm ist der Vorsitzende
der Programm und grundsatzkommission der
also sich
2022 auf den Weg gemacht hat um seiner
Partei dieses neue Grundsatzprogramm zu
geben in dieser Zeit ist schon eine
ganze Menge passiert es gab zum Beispiel
vier Regionalkonferenzen bei den
Mitgliederinnen und Mitglieder
zusammengekommen sind um darüber zu
sprechen wie ihre Partei in den
kommenden Jahren aussehen soll es gab
einen größeren Zukunftskongress es gab
eine Mitgliederbefragung an der über 6
und 60.000 Mitglieder der CDU
teilgenommen haben
und nun ist es also an der Zeit sich
auch Impulse von außen zu holen
das hat Mario Czaja gerade schon kurz
auch referiert
nachdem Carsten Linnemann gleich
gesprochen haben wird wird es eine
Diskussion geben mit
verschiedenen Vertretern aus
verschiedenen Schichten der Gesellschaft
aus verschiedenen Branchen auch Tanja
Gönner wird damit dabei sein die
Hauptgeschäftsführerin des
Bundesverbandes der deutschen Industrie
Michael vasiliad ist der Vorsitzende der
Industriegewerkschaft Bergbau Chemie und
Energie evil Maria welscop.de fahr die
Präsidentin des deutschen Caritas
verwandtes Claudia Pechstein
sportliche Impulse also von der
fünfmaligen Olympiasiegerin und
weltweiten Rekord winterolympionikin
Ruben Giuliano ist dabei ein Podcaster
Vorsitzender der Initiative
Jugendparlament und moderiert wird das
Ganze gleich dann von Christina stumpf
der stellvertretenden Generalsekretärin
der CDU
[Musik]
jetzt aber erstmal Zeit für Carsten
Linnemann den stellvertretenden
Bundesvorsitzenden und Vorsitzenden der
Programm und grundsatzkommission
vielen Dank
ein tolles Omen lieber Friedrich Merz
lieber Mario Czaja liebe Christina
Stumpp ich freue mich dass der
Ministerpräsident da ist aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen lieber Hendrik wüst
der Vorsitzende der Adenauer Stiftung
lieber Professor Dr Lammert Prälat dr
Jüsten aus Sie herzlich willkommen
stellvertretend für die Kolleginnen und
Kollegen freue ich mich dass ja viele da
sind aus den
Parlamenten aus dem Europaparlament aus
den Landtagen den Deutschen Bundestag
eine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren ich
möchte sie stellvertretend begrüßen auch
im Namen
von serapühler und Mario Vogt und vor
allen Dingen freue ich mich dass wir 150
Gäste zu Gast haben die
wahrscheinlich zum großen Teil zum
ersten Mal auf einer CDU-Veranstaltung
sind die uns unterstützen wollen die
ihren Gehirnschmalz mitbringen
um die CDU nach vorne zu bringen
herzlichen Dank dass Sie da sind
herzlichen Dank für Ihre Unterstützung
das ist wirklich große Klasse
der Weg zu unserem Grundsatzprogramm
begann am
21 bzw 26 September
2021 wir hatten die Bundestagswahl
verloren und wir hatten sie deshalb
verloren weil die CDU nicht mehr gut
genug war
wir möchten dies jetzt korrigieren mit
dem vierten Programm
wir möchten die CDU wieder auf die Höhe
der Zeit bringen
heute
ungefähr vor 46 Jahren haben wir uns
hier getroffen
in Berlin ich war nicht mit dabei
im Haus der Kulturen der Welt die
Berliner sagen auch Schwangere Auster
wir haben uns auch dort getroffen mit ja
der Historiker Michael Borchert hat
gesagt die CDU war die erste Partei die
sich geöffnet hat
das war ein Novum dass man wenn es um
ein Parteiprogramm ging um einen
Grundsatzprogramm
Personen außerhalb der Partei aus
verschiedenen gesellschaftlichen Gruppen
eingeladen hat es war ja sozusagen
Innovation
und daran schließen
und damit das funktioniert brauchen Sie
zwei Dinge erstens
wir brauchen Offenheit für neue Ideen
und zweitens die Bereitschaft zur
Debatte die Bereitschaft zur Debatte
funktioniert nur wenn es keine
Denkverbote gibt
und es gibt eine Person
die nicht nur gesagt hat wir führen
diesen Prozess jetzt fort den Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer begonnen hat sondern
der gesagt hat hört auf
parteitaktisch zu denken
politstrategisch zu denken hört auf
darüber nachzudenken was könnte die
Schlagzeile am nächsten Tag sein sondern
in diesem grundsatzprogrammprozess
möchte ich das sachlich gearbeitet wird
und so gearbeitet wird dass Deutschlands
Zukunft gewonnen wird nicht verloren
geht wir reden hier über die Sache und
deshalb möchte ich mich herzlich
bedanken im Namen wenn ich das sagen
darf der gesamten Partei lieber
Friedrich Merz herzlichen Dank dass du
diese Debattenkultur ein vor das ist
genau der Grund warum es so gut läuft an
dieser Stelle vielen vielen
vielen Dank es ist so
nicht normal
in welcher Zeit schreiben wir dieses
Grundsatzprogramm mario hat einige
Punkte
in den Rückspiegel schauen
aber schauen sich einfach mal die letzte
Dekade an
in der letzten Dekade gab es den am
längsten anhaltenden wirtschaftlichen
ausschwung den dieses Land seit
Jahrzehnten glaube sie müssten in die
Geschichtsbücher zurückgehen ins 19
Jahrhundert
um sowas schon mal gesehen zu haben
ich will die Nummer ein Indikator nennen
der wichtig ist volkswirtschaftlich um
die Menge Lage zu skizzieren ist nämlich
die Jugendarbeitslosigkeit die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit ging in diesem
Land von 12,5% im Jahre 2005
auf unter 5% zurück im Jahre 2021
das ist der Verdienst
unserer Wirtschaftsordnung unserer
sozialen Marktwirtschaft das ist der
Verdienst was sie alles Frau Gönner der
tarifpartnerschaft der Gewerkschaften
und der arbeitgeberverbindung das ist
der Verdienst der Arbeitnehmerinnen und
Arbeitnehmer und Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitgeberin und
allen unberufen zum Trotz auch der
politischen Rahmenbedingungen die in
dieser Zeit gesetzt wurden und auch das
muss erwähnt werden um diesen
grundsatzprogrammprozess in die
richtigen Bahnen zu lenken
diese Entwicklung
hat beim letzten Grundsatzprogramm 2007
niemand hat voraussehen können wir
hatten die Finanzkrise die
Subprime-Krise aus Amerika schlug wie
ein Blitz im Sommer 2007 in Deutschland
ein
in dem Jahr haben wir das
Grundsatzprogramm geschrieben das letzte
das dritte und in dem Jahr wurde das
iPhone erfunden wir konnten es nicht
voraussehen auch wie die Welt sich
insgesamt entwickelt und heute
heute können wir es erahnen
der Zeiten Wandel
geopolitisch
militärisch begründet aber vermutlich
werden den 10 Jahren in 15 Jahren und
das ist das Zeitfenster unseres
Grundsatzprogramms über eine
Epochenwende reden
die tektonischen Machtverschiebungen
sind offenkundig China EBT seit einigen
Jahren in Anspruch ökonomisch
militärisch und politisch die Nummer
eins zu werden von der Situation
erprobte herrlich
kaum noch drüber berichtet
atomwaffenpflege
Raketentest die Amerikaner
jenseits des Atlantiks haben nicht mehr
die Funktion der weltpolizeien sondern
sehen verstärkt
ihre eigenen Interessen auf diesem
Globus und die Europäer müssen aufpassen
dass sie nicht zum spielbar werden
zwischen diesen Supermächten wir haben
die mega Themen Klima und Migration
beim Thema Klima
am großen Kongress gehabt auch hier im
Rahmen des grundsatzprogrammprozesses
wissen wir was das für die
Innovationskraft nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern auch in Europa und
weltweit leben müssen
um dieser Frage her zu werden beim Thema
Migration
hat Bundespräsident Joachim Gauck leider
recht gehabt
unser Herz ist weit
doch unsere Möglichkeiten sind endlich
wir sehen heute das 350.000 Kita Plätze
fehlen 700.000
Wohnungen
und
kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen 1700
Kinder beispielsweise die hier in Berlin
auf der Warteliste stehen im
schulfähigen Alter Kinder von
Zugewanderten die eigentlich zur Schule
gehen müssten aber nicht gehen können
weil die Kapazitäten fehlen
das ist der Befund
und er geht mitten ins Mark
und gleichzeitig
erleben Sie eine Welt die immer
schneller wird wir sind doch alle
gestresst
du kriegst eine WhatsApp und musst
sofort antworten
noch nie gab es so viele Burnouts und
kriegen ja kaum noch Termine
ja woran liegt das denn ja die
Geschwindigkeit die ist ja auch extrem
ich meine sie müssen sich das mal
vorstellen die erste industrielle
Revolution hat 100 Jahre gedauert
von der Agrarwirtschaft bis zur ersten
Industrie
die zweite Revolution 60 70 Jahre
Massenproduktion Fließbandarbeit
Elektrizität die dritte Revolution nur
noch 20 30 Jahre Computer Robotik
Mikroelektronik die vierte Generation
die digitale Transformation 10 15 Jahre
jetzt stehen wir zu Schwelle ja zu
fünften das was der Quantencomputer in
wenigen Sekunden erledigt dafür brauchte
der kommt der normale Computer Hunderte
von Stunden
wir werden im Jahre 2035 so die
Prognostiker kein Berufsbild mehr sehen
keins
Klammer auf die meisten Berufsbilder die
es dann gibt kennen wir heute noch nicht
kein Berufsbild mehr sehen was nicht von
künstlicher Intelligenz
unterstützt wird und in so einer Zeit
haben wir es auf der anderen Seite mit
einem Staat zu tun
der zunehmend bevormundet
ist besser es vermeintlich besser weiß
als der einzige
und gleichzeitig ausufert wer sticken
quasi als Bürger als Unternehmen in
Bürokratie und Überregulierung am Ende
des Tages
und das ist die Gefahr auf diesem Weg
befindet sich dieses Land entsteht ein
Staat der alle Aufgaben an sich zieht
und jedes Problem und jede
Herausforderung mit Geld zu schüttet
und die Eigenverantwortung des Einzelnen
geht dabei vor die Hunde wenn Sie nicht
persönlich fragen
ist das eine der zentralsten Fragen
dieser Zeit wie schaffen die es in
Zeiten steigenden Wohlstandes wieder der
Eigenverantwortung das Wort zu reden
schon Ludwig Erhard ich hatte das Glück
mit kotiden Kopf über diese Frage zu
reden Ludwig er der Erfinder der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft hat kurz vor
seinem Tode 1977 Kurt Biedenkopf gesagt
ich hätte nie gedacht
dass es jetzt schon Tendenzen gibt also
damals in den 70er Jahren das mit
steigendem Wohlstand die
Eigenverantwortung des Einzelnen abnimmt
diese Frage ist zentral für unseren
Prozess
aber wenn Sie das jetzt mal alles
zusammenfassen diese Standortanalyse und
sich die Frage stellen die auf mehreren
Ebenen stattfindet
wie muss die Politik wie müssen wir im
Licht dessen dass wir über die nächsten
10 15 Jahre sprechen auf diese Situation
reagieren und ich habe nur über das
gesprochen was absehbar ist das was
nicht absehbar ist wird noch mal
größeren Raum einnehmen und ich kann
Ihnen sagen es geht nur um zwei Punkte
oder erstmal um einen Punkt wenn ich ihn
zusammenfasse die Menschen haben eine
Sehnsucht nach Halt und Orientierung in
so einer komplexen Welt
und die CDU muss es sein die diesen
Menschen wieder Halt und Orientierung
gibt und um das zu schaffen brauchen Sie
zwei Dinge erstens ein Kompass
und zweitens ein Ziel ganz einfach
den Kompass haben wir den haben wir im
letzten Jahr verabschiedet auf dem
Bundesparteitag in Hannover
dreh- und Angelpunkt wenn Sie so wollen
die Nadel des Kompass
ist das C
das christliche Menschenbild ist die DNA
der CDU und nicht verhandelbar es drückt
er richtet sich alles noch aus alles
es drückt aus
dass wir Politik für die Menschen machen
und nicht gegen sie oder anders
ausgedrückt
es drückt aus
dass wir die Menschen so nehmen wie sie
sind und nicht wie sie sein sollten das
muss CDU-Politik sein gerade in diesen
Zeiten
Frederik Merz fand hat auch eine tolle
Formulierung am 30 mai bei unserem
Auftakt 2022 gefunden ich zitiere wir
Christdemokraten Glauben an den Menschen
weil wir an seine Stärken und
Fähigkeiten glauben
weil wir jeden einzelnen und seinen
Betrag für das große Ganze sehen das ist
der Geist der uns auf dem Weg zu einem
neuen Grundsatzprogramm ein Zitat Ende
das ist unser Kompass und das Ziel
wir machen heute mal so
ein Versuch
mit dem Bild
nicht nur bitte schwarz-weiß machen auch
ein paar Farben
wir sollen ein Deutschland-Bild malen in
diesem Grundsatzprogramm Prozess und
deshalb sind sie hier wir sind mitten
auf dem Weg wir haben
Regionalkonferenzen gemacht Mitglieder
Befragung und vieles mehr und heute
spielt dieser Kongress der wird
historisch werden eine extrem große
Rolle wir werden alles dokumentieren was
später in den Foren Diskutiert wird wir
werden das mitnehmen und am Ende des
Tages muss so in Deutschland stehen
und das machen die Fachkommissionen
und er möchte mich beeilen vorsitzen und
Stellvertretern dieser Fachkommission
begleiten die das richtig gut machen
und ich kann nichts vorwegnehmen weil es
auch nichts gibt vorwegzunehmen weil wir
ja mitten im Prozess sind aber hier und
da Mario ciao hat gesagt gibt es
Konturen
es gibt Konturen das heißt für uns wir
wollen nicht nur im Grundsätzlichen
bleiben sondern wollen anhand einiger
weniger konkreter Beispiele zeigen was
wir denn mit dem grundsätzlichen meinen
und da gibt es Konturen die stärker
werden
dass wir beispielsweise uns darauf
geeinigt haben dass wir ein
gesellschaftsjahr wollen
weil wir glauben für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt ist
sowas wichtig
wir bereiten uns jetzt zwei Jahre vor
Mario Entscheid hat eine Arbeitsgruppe
wir reden mit allen Akteuren
aber wir glauben dass es dieser
Gesellschaft gut tut wenn die
unterschiedlichen gesellschaftlichen
Gruppen
miteinander reden muss man gelinde
auszudrücken und spüren dass der
Andersdenkende kein Feind ist sondern
dass er einfach nur eine andere Meinung
hat und dass das richtig ist für eine
Demokratie und wenn dieses
gesellschaftsjahr noch Orientierung gibt
und soziale Kompetenzen vermittelt dann
ist es rund wir müssen aber dieses
gesellschaftsjahr so konzipieren das ist
so viele Optionen gibt in der Breite das
zu machen also nicht nur zur
bundeswehren Feuerwehr sozialen Dienste
sondern auch europäisches Ausland weiß
ich nicht Vereine Stiftung dass die
jungen Menschen sagen ich habe da Bock
drauf ich finde das gut
und ich freue mich auch dass der
Bundespräsident dieses Thema
unterstützt denn am Ende des Tages kann
man so ein Thema nicht durchdrücken als
Partei sondern da brauchen sie einen
gesellschaftlichen Konsens
oder ich sehe kein Josef Laumann
er kümmert sich bei uns um die sozialen
Themen soziale Sicherheit
mit Michael Kretschmer leitet er die
Kommission
und da wollen wir auch CDU-Politik
machen dass wir sagen Subsidiarität und
Solidarität die Eigenverantwortung in
den Mittelpunkt stehen und jeder der
diese Eigenverantwortung nicht
nachkommen kann auch die volle
Unterstützung ich betone die volle
Unterstützung des Staates
dass wenn jemand nicht arbeiten kann aus
welchen Gründen auch immer er voll
unterstützt wird und auf der anderen
Seite jemand der Arbeiten kann auch
arbeiten muss weil die
Solidargemeinschaft wenn er denn die
Solidargemeinschaft nutzt auch dieses
sehen will es ist allein schon wichtig
für die Akzeptanz
oder dass wir bei den Renten Fragen
natürlich darüber viel stärker noch
nachdenken müssen Mario was machen wir
mit Leuten die Leben lang gearbeitet
haben die müssen signifikant mehr haben
als andere
wie können wir Anreizen auch nicht
verbieten oder was auch immer dass
Menschen wenn sie denn wollen freiwillig
länger arbeiten warum sagt man nicht
einfach mal bis zu einem bestimmten
Betrag wenn jemand das gesetzliche
Rentenalter erreicht kann man steuerfrei
weiter arbeiten muss das Problem ich sag
ihm nach zwei Jahren sind alle
begeistert
und es werden noch 80 90 Prozent derer
vielleicht jetzt machen die sonst nicht
gemacht hätten einfach mal machen
einfach mal ausprobieren oder nehmen Sie
die Minijobs in Deutschland darüber
müssen wir reden
kann auch nicht sein das ist
Hunderttausende von Menschen gibt ihm
Vollzeitjob haben und nebenbei Minijob
für 450 oder 520 €. ja warum haben die
denn nebenbei weil die zusätzliche
Stunde Arbeit nicht mehr lohnt weil über
60%
warum sagen wir nicht die ÖVP diskutiert
das gerade in Österreich wenn einer
Vollzeit arbeitet 40 Stunden und darüber
aus eine Überstunde macht ist das
steuerfrei natürlich muss er Beiträge
zahlen ich möchte einfach in einem Land
leben wo solche Vorschläge diskutiert
werden wo nicht die Bedenkenträger und
Bremser kommen wo wir Dinge mal
ausprobieren auch vor Ort denn nur so
kommen wir weiter und das muss der Geist
sein der dieses Programm hat
könnt ihr noch sich Themen nennen aus
verschiedenen Kommission ich sehe Karin
Prien hier Silvia breher euch alle
ich möchte es dabei werden lassen nur
dass sie Gespür bekommen wo wir hin
wollen
und lassen sie mich zum Schluss
auch sagen ja wir brauchen dieses Bild
in Farbe
mit schwarz-weiß werden sie die Menschen
nicht begeistern
wenn wir Lust auf Zukunft machen wollen
braucht dieses Land wieder Optimismus
dieses Land braucht Zuversicht und Mut
wir müssen die Verzagtheit und die
letter die die es hier gibt ablegen wir
brauchen Aufbruch und Erneuerung wir
müssen ein Klima schaffen dass wenn
Menschen eine Idee haben einfach mal
loslaufen können und es umsetzen können
und nicht das andere kommen und sagen es
geht nicht weil
das muss
das muss der Geist sein
CDU
ist nur dann wählbar wenn wir diesen
Aufbruch und diese Erneuerung verkörpern
und wir waren es Marie du hast es gesagt
in den letzten Jahren Wolfgang Schäuble
auch einfach kann jeder schwierig können
wir diesen Prozess ziehen wir jetzt
durch ja ich kenne die Kritik dass es
lange dauert nein wir brauchen die Zeit
wir brauchen unser Fundament wieder wir
brauchen eine Erkennungsmelodie und wir
brauchen Punkte die uns von anderen
unterscheiden deshalb sind sie hier
vielen Dank für ihr Kommen auf geht's
und schönen Tag an alle und einer
erfolgreichen danke
da hat jemand so richtig Bock auf diesen
Grundsatz Konvent hier in Berlin
Karsten Lindemann der stellvertretende
Bundesvorsitzende Vorsitzende auch der
Programm und grundsatzkommission der
diesen Prozess diese Erarbeitung des
neuen Grundsatzprogramms der CDU auf dem
Weg gebracht hat
2022 unter diesen Prozess fest in seinen
Händen hält einfach mal machen einfach
mal ausprobieren
Verzagtheit Lethargie ablegen das ist
das Motto
und jetzt ist Christina stumpf dran die
stellvertretende Generalsekretärin der
CDU die gleich eine impulsrunde
moderieren wird mit fünf Gästen die ich
eben schon mal genannt habe Tanja Gönner
wird das sein die Hauptgeschäftsführerin
des Bundesverbandes der deutschen
Industrie Michael vasiliadis der
Vorsitzende der Industrie Gewerkschaft
Bergbau Chemie und Energie Eva Maria
Wels kommt der Fahrt die Präsidentin des
Deutschen Caritasverbandes Claudia
Pechstein fünfmalige Olympiasiegerin und
Eisschnellläuferin und Ruben Giuliano
Podcaster und Vorsitzender der
Initiative Jugendparlament
Werte wo wollen wir unser Land wie
möchten wir für unser Land voranbringen
und gestalten was ist unser
Deutschland-Bild das geht natürlich
nicht in reiner Selbstbestimmung unser
Anspruch als Volkspartei ist es
verschiedenste gesellschaftliche
Anliegen und Strömungen aufzugreifen und
ihnen ein politisches Zuhause zu geben
deshalb freue ich mich sehr dass wir
heute fünf herausragende Stimmen
gewinnen konnten die stellvertreten für
alle Kernbereiche unserer Gesellschaft
stehen sie werden uns mit auf den Weg
geben was ihre Erwartungen an unser
Grundsatzprogramm sind was ihre zentrale
Forderungen auch sind was wir mit
aufnehmen möchten und sollen damit
möchte ich auf die Bühne bitten zunächst
eine starke Stimme der deutschen
Wirtschaft sie ist
Hauptgeschäftsführerin des
Bundesverbandes der deutschen Industrie
und langjährige ver trauensvolle
Ansprechpartnerin sie kommt ich aus dem
schöne Ländle in Baden-Württemberg
herzlich willkommen Tanja Gönner
[Applaus]
als nächstes unsere heutige Stimme der
Arbeitnehmerschaft und ihre Anliegen es
freut uns ganz besonders dass der
Vorsitzende der Industriegewerkschaft
Bergbau Chemie und Energie bei uns ist
herzlich willkommen Michael wasilad ist
[Musik]
unsere nächste Impulsgeberin ist
Leiterin des Wohlfahrtsverbandes der
katholischen Kirche in Deutschland der
Caritas sie bereichert unsere Runde mit
ihrem Blick aus Sicht notbedürftiger und
auf den Fokus unserer Hilfsorganisation
es freut mich ganz besonders herzlich
willkommen Eva Maria Wels kommt Stefan
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und die vierte Impulsgeberin steht wie
keine zweite für Einsatz von und
Leistungsbereitschaft sie ist fünffache
Olympiasiegerin und Rekord
winterolympion heute ist sie unsere
Stimme des Sports und unserer Vereine
herzlich willkommen Claudia Pechstein
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und zu guter Letzt möchte ich unseren
Impulsgeber für die Anliegen junger
politisch engagierter Menschen auf die
Bühnen bitten es ist erst Vorsitzender
der Initiative Jugendparlament die die
Funktionsweise unseres politischen
System erlebbar macht und für dafür
natürlich auch wirkt sich
gesellschaftlich zu engagieren herzlich
willkommen Ruben Giuliano
[Applaus]
[Musik]
schön dass sie heute alle bei uns sind
wir sind schon ganz gespannt auf die
Runde und wir fangen an mit Tanja Gönner
liebe Frau Gönner in fünf Minuten auf
den Punkt gebracht was denn ihre
Erwartungen an unser Grundsatzprogramm
was muss für die Wirtschaft drinstehen
wir freuen uns auf Ihren Impuls
ja ganz herzlichen Dank liebe Christina
stumpf lieber Friedrich Merz lieber
Mario Czaja liebe Mitglieder des
Bundesvorstands der CDU des
Bundesausschusses Ländervertreter meine
sehr geehrter sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren ich freue mich natürlich heute
hier sein zu dürfen und tatsächlich als
Wirtschaft ins Gespräch mit ihnen zu
kommen weil so verstehe ich das was
gemacht wird ins Gespräch kommen und
miteinander im Austausch sein und nicht
nur zu sagen was fordern wir weil das
eine ist Forderungen aufstellen das
andere ist darüber sprechen warum es so
ist und das glaube ich ist eigentlich
wenn ich Carsten lehnemann richtig
verstanden habe was gewünscht wird und
die große Herausforderung glaube ich ist
dass wir zwar im Tagesgeschäft in vielen
Detailfragen sind ja wir sind im Hier
und Jetzt und müssen schauen wie wir
dort arbeiten aber ja es ist noch viel
wichtiger auch immer wieder auf die
Grundlagen und die Grundsätze
zurückzukommen und zu verstehen wofür
und wohin geht es und wer hat welche
Rolle und deswegen freue ich mich hier
zu sein letzten Endes geht es darum dass
wir unsere Unternehmen vor
Herausforderungen stehen aber genauso
die Volkswirtschaft und die Gesellschaft
insgesamt und diese im Moment in der
Frage der Veränderungen in denen wir
leben sehr grundlegend sind und deswegen
für die Frage was sind die Grundsätze
aus meiner Sicht und die Grundlagen die
wichtig sind erstens für uns gilt nach
wie vor als deutsche Wirtschaft die
soziale Marktwirtschaft ist und sollte
weiterhin die Grundlage des Wohlstands
bleiben Wirtschaft ist wichtiger Teil
der Gesellschaft das ist nicht nur
unsere tiefe Auffassung als BDI sondern
die Erfolgsgeschichte der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft hat uns gezeigt wie
Prosperität geschaffen doch Fleisch und
Ideenreichtum unseren gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt getragen hat das reicht vom
Ausgleich der Lebensverhältnisse bis zum
sozialen aufstiegsversprechen unter
Sicherheit dass niemanden Notlagen
allein gelassen wird und diese
Errungenschaften sind unweigerlich mit
einer starken wirtschaftlichen Basis und
Wachstum über die letzten acht
Jahrzehnte verbunden und damit das
zweite Europa und damit der europäische
Binnenmarkt es ist der zweite wichtige
Erfolgsfaktor für das wo wir heute
stehen ein Erbe eines cdu-kanzlers und
ich sage es heute auch deswegen weil wir
im 30 Jubiläumsjahr des europäischen
Binnenmarktes derzeit stehen dieser
nicht nur ein unschätzbaren Wert in der
Geschichte der europäischen Integration
sondern er war und ist Treiber unseres
Wachstums und der Grund weshalb wir in
Europa und gestanden sie mehr an der
Stelle zu sagen noch global
konkurrenzfähig sind sie werden
verstehen am Ende warum ich von noch
spreche diese zwei Grundlagen haben uns
in der Vergangenheit getragen und
Wohlstand geschaffen allerdings sehen
wir uns vor der Herausforderung dass
diese Selbstverständlichkeit hinterfragt
wird und Karsten Linnemann hat ja darauf
diesen was schon Ludwig Gerhardter
Erfinder der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
gemerkt hat und das glaube ich ist das
was uns ziert damit zum dritten was sind
eigentlich Grundlagen was sind neue
Herausforderungen aber eigentlich auch
schon Grundlagen Energie war immer
Grundlage des erfolgreichen
Wirtschaftens und damit habe ich glaube
ich schon eines der zentralen
Herausforderungen umschrieben weil ja
Energie war günstig dafür muss man sich
nicht entschuldigen wenn ich das auch
mal deutlich sagen darf und wir brauchen
damit wir Industriestandort bleiben und
dieses Land hat seinen Erfolg durch das
Zusammenwirken der großen
Betriebe unter mittelständischen
Betriebe in diesem Netzwerk sind wir
stark nicht die großen gegen die Kleinen
sondern nur im Netzwerk ist dieser
Wirtschaftsstandort stark und das muss
uns immer klar sein nicht den einen
gegen den anderen schicken sondern bitte
immer integriert verstehen weil wenn das
einen schlecht geht wird es dauerhaft
auch den anderen schlecht gehen und ich
sage das deswegen
weil ich nicht sicher bin ob noch
verstanden wird hier ja aber das
Deutschland Industriestandort bleiben
muss und Industriestandort bleiben soll
weil wir nur dann erfolgreich sind damit
gibt es aber eine neue Herausforderung
die gern unter Resilienz beschrieben
wird was ist das und das ist glaube ich
die neue Herausforderung Ökonomie wird
heute zum Gegenstand und vor allen
Dingen die globalisierte Ökonomie wird
heute zum Gegenstand von Geopolitik und
sich darin einzurichten und darüber
nachzudenken was heißt es im neuen
zusammen wirken zwischen Staat
Gesellschaft und Unternehmen wird glaube
ich die zentrale Herausforderung sein
das wird heute nicht umschrieben über
Industriepolitik und ja natürlich gibt
es glaube ich heute veränderte
Rahmenbedingungen und ja wir müssen uns
unterhalten was sind die Dinge die dazu
führen dass wir Resilienz sind als
Gesellschaft aber genauso als Staat und
damit auch als Wirtschaft und uns
darüber unterhalten wie wir das dann
auch gemeinsam erreichen können das
strategische Abhängigkeiten anders
angegangen werden können das glaube ich
sind Veränderungen im Grundsätzlichen
nichtsdestot das würde ich sagen das
ordnungspolitisch wenn ich darüber
spreche vier Ziele im Vordergrund stehen
sollten stabile Lieferketten
technologiefähigkeit erlangen und
ausbauen industrielle Fertigkeiten zu
wahren der eigenen Handlungsfähigkeiten
verstärken und die internationale
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit behaupten also mit
fairem und effektivem Handel wer gegen
Handel ist und wer gegen fairen Handel
ist schadet Deutschland und Europa
und damit letzter Teil weil ich glaube
das ist das Wesentliche und das ist das
was für uns wichtig ist wir brauchen
eine heute veränderte und doch wieder
auch Rückbesinnung der Frage der
Beziehung zwischen Staat und Wirtschaft
es wurde gesagt der Mensch strebt nach
Freiheit die Wirtschaft strebt nicht nur
nach Freiheit sondern Wirtschaft braucht
Freiheit damit sie handeln kann und
wir brauchen ein Verhältnis zwischen
Staat und Wirtschaft des von Vertrauen
nicht von Misstrauen geprägt ist wir
brauchen eine Gesellschaft die versteht
das Industrien nicht schlecht ist ich
nehme wahr dass wieder gerne über
Kapitalismus gesprochen wird ja ich
stehe hier dann bin ich Vertreterin der
Kapitalisten positive Kapitalismus trägt
zum Wohlstand bei dafür steht die
soziale Marktwirtschaft und dafür werden
wir weiter eintreten
und deswegen wirklich der Wunsch wir
brauchen einen Staat der Unternehmen
ernst nimmt im übrigen auch eine
Gesellschaft Ihnen beste Infrastruktur
stellt Prozesse beschleunigt und nicht
Hemd attraktiv für Fachkräfte ist
internationale Kooperation sucht und
eine klare Haltung gegenüber Autokratien
und Menschenrechtsverletzungen einnimmt
das ist wichtig für uns der Staat darf
nicht personalistisch über die
Unternehmen beugen und versuchen jeden
Schritt bis ins Detail zu regulieren
bitte setzen Sie diesen Rahmen auch bei
der Frage der Grundsätze besinnen wir
uns wirklich auf den Kern der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft Grenzen wir womöglich
wieder klare Verantwortungsbereiche und
Freiheiten ab zwischenstaat und
Unternehmen definieren wir wo
Zusammenarbeit unerlässlich ist bei der
Verantwortung vertrauen wir einander und
ziehen an einem Strang dann bin ich sehr
zuverlässig dass den vergangenen acht
erfolgreichen Jahrzehnten noch viele
neue erfolgreiche Jahrzehnte Folgen
werden herzlichen Dank
Tanja Gönner die Hauptgeschäftsführerin
des Bundesverbandes der deutschen
Industrie die vor allem eine Sache in
den Fokus gestellt hat Start und
Wirtschaft müssen eng zusammenarbeiten
aber der Staat dürfen die Wirtschaft
nicht paternalistisch einen engen
Freiheit das Gebot der Stunde
jetzt Michael vasileadis Vorsitzender
der IG BCE
[Musik]
habe
dass die politische Mitte sozusagen den
politischen Streit führt aber nicht
Kampf des politischen Streit führt der
eine gesellschaftliche Balance braucht
denn den Kern wenn ich mal ihre Worte
noch einmal
zusammenfasse und ihre Titel der
vergangenen
Programme Freiheit Solidarität
Gerechtigkeit könnte auch ein
gewerkschaftsprogramm sein die Frage ist
was ja ich will diese Linie ernsthaft
ziehen
ich sag moderne Demokratien sind
entstanden sozusagen im Kampf um
Freiheit und der Balance was heißt denn
das jetzt und diese Debatte ist glaube
ich eine unglaublich wichtige Debatte um
die politische Mitte die moderne
politische Mitte zu definieren warum wir
haben nicht nur noch die Mitte die
hatten wir aber mal das überhaupt
wahrzunehmen und ich sagen das ist ein
Phänomen das irgendwie wieder weggeht
das ist glaube ich wichtig sie haben
klare Worte gefunden das ist mir auch
wichtig
ich weiß ja wohl und ich sag das hier
sehr deutlich ich meine link sextreme
und rechtsextrem ich meine links und
rechts
und
dass das dass das eben politischen
tagesstreiten Schlagabtausch das ist
klar wir sind aber hier beim Grundsatz
beim Grundsatz gibt es auch eine
Sozialdemokratie die eben keine
Kommunisten sind und so sind auch diese
Fragen noch mal ernsthaft zu betrachten
was sind eigentlich die langen Linien
und dann will ich mich auch als
Gewerkschaft aber wir vereinen natürlich
in der Einheitsgewerkschaft auch alle
diese Spenden ich habe 600.000
Mitglieder immer noch
das sind immer noch mehr als jede
politische Partei und da drin habe ich
alle und es muss mir gelingen sozusagen
diese Balance natürlich thematisch
fokussierter als eine Partei das ist ja
klar aber ich muss die zusammenhalten
und dieser Versuch auszubalancieren ist
in der heutigen Zeit nicht sexy wenn man
Wahlen gewinnen will muss man dieses
Verhältnis managen und das tun sie ja
gerade wie kann man das Verständnis so
sind eigentlich die Menschen von
Vernunft Stabilität Ausgleich und fern
ist ins Verhältnis setzen in solch einer
Zeit des Umbruches da bin ich beim
zweiten Thema was macht Deutschland
stark
eine starke starkes Blick auf eine
starke Wirtschaft wenn wir das verlieren
wird alles schwerer alles deswegen von
der Industriepolitik bis zur Frage
innovationsgängigkeiten neuer
wirtschaftliche Aktivitäten wir müssen
das ganze 88 tasteige Piano und nicht so
ein tempiorgel bespielen also das Ding
braucht es da kann es auch mal Misstöne
geben wer aber sagt dass wir die
wirtschaftliche Grundlage in Frage
stellen können der verspielt alles
zweiter Punkt
zweiter Punkt kann man deshalb so
weitermachen wie bisher brauche ich
nicht kommentieren es gibt viele viele
Indikatoren nicht nur Klimaschutz auch
andere Dinge die sagt wir müssen etwas
Neues finden das ist der Kern der
Debatte was ist das und wie können wir
wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sein ohne uns
abzuschotten ohne uns sozusagen
auszuliefern und mit den Stärken die
Deutschland hat erste Nachricht wir
haben Stärken glauben Sie es mir wir
haben Stärken ja das muss man ja sagen
und die zu stärken ist einfach viel viel
logischer als sozusagen was neues
dagegen zu setzen wie können wir das
geht nicht immer ich bin derjenige den
Kohleausstieg mit managen muss das ging
halt nicht mehr aber
zumindestens sich Mühe zu geben zu
prüfen ob das was wir können wir können
ja nicht alles ob das dazu beitragen
kann dass das was wir wollen schneller
besser geht das doch wohl die Mühe wert
und deshalb bin ich auch Feuer und
Flamme für Industriepolitik das geht
nicht alleine wir brauchen den Markt und
wir müssen so viel Markt wie möglich
aber wenn wir das einfach laufen lassen
klappt es nicht wenn wir alles
regulieren auch nicht also wieder eine
balancefrage komme ich zum Kern meine
Zeit läuft ab also ich meine sondern
ihre äh jedenfalls
jedenfalls wir müssen wir müssen das was
das Land kann natürlich auch mit dem und
ihr Spruch war ja nicht nur Freiheit
sondern in der Vergangenheit Freiheit
und Sicherheit sie meinten das anders
aber ich will das mal um definieren wenn
wir dem Land in der Transformation den
Menschen nicht ein gewisses gerade alle
Aufbruch den finde ich gut aber ein paar
Eckpunkte an Sicherheit wollen sogar die
Manager haben ich habe keinen einzigen
Manager Vertrag unterschrieben wo die
gesagt haben ich weiß nicht was die
verdienen will die schau mal mache ich
vom Erfolg abhängig gibt es nicht mehr
also die haben alle auch ein Interesse
an sich ja und das meine ich jetzt auch
ganz ernst
wir müssen nicht jedes Detail die fünfte
Stelle hinterm Komma versichern das muss
nicht sein aber die wesentlichen Dinge
und das ist auch die Tradition der Union
und nicht nur in dem christlichen
sondern eher caritativen Sinne sondern
auch systematisch wir müssen in der
Transformation uns über die Frage was
ist Sicherheit und ich meine vor allen
Dingen soziale Sicherheit unterhalten
das was die fundamentalsten Fragen sind
ist ja klar aber wie ist das Spektrum
damit wir an der Stelle und das machen
wir ja auch als Gewerkschaften wir
schaffen einen Rahmen und was tun wir
dann wenn es Transformation gibt
wir tauschen Vertrauen heute gegen
Chance von morgen und man glaubt uns und
da drin steckt das Geheimnis schaffen
wir das so konkret zu bekommen dass die
Menschen wirklich glauben dass das
klappt und da gibt es eine Menge und da
erzähle ich auf die Union ich bin auch
nicht sicher ob sie hinbringen also
machen Sie es
machen sie es wir brauchen
keinen avantismus in dieser Debatte wir
brauchen die Verbindung der
Transformation mit dem Leben der
Menschen werden es im letzten Jahr
gesehen was passiert wenn plötzlich die
harten Irritation Gaskrise durchschlagen
das ist sofort ein entspannungsthema wir
müssen den Leuten Sicherheit geben und
sie wirklich in die Lage zu versetzen
die Kräfte freizusetzen Herr Lindemann
von der sie gesprochen haben und da
haben sie einen guten Partner das sind
wir
so dann bringen sie uns auch in die Lage
helfen Sie uns die Dinge die die soziale
Marktwirtschaft auch beinhalten sie
müssen nicht unsere Mitglieder werden
aber ich erwarte von Ihnen dass es nicht
so ein Art stilles Gentleman agreement
mit Zinken der Tarifbindung gibt ich
erwarte von Ihnen dass Sie Betriebsräte
Stärken auch wenn es mal kompliziert
wird Rate von Ihnen dass wir von
Grundsatz
beieinander bleiben schreiben Sie es
auch auf ich helfe Ihnen dann auch
vielen Dank Glückauf
michael war sie geladen ist der
Vorsitzende der Industrie Gewerkschaft
IG BCE mit einer sehr direkten Ansprache
an den CDU-Vorstand und den Wunsch die
wirtschaftliche Grundlage in diesem Land
nicht in Frage zu stellen er hatte
richtig festgestellt seine Zeit läuft ab
er hat nur wenig Zeit zu sprechen das
ganze hier in Berlin läuft ein bisschen
den Zeitplan hinterher das ist aber
nicht ungewöhnlich bei solchen Partei
Tagen da wird dann auch gerne mal ein
bisschen das überschritten
ja was im Programm steht an Zeit jetzt
ist Eva Maria Wels kommt die Präsidentin
des Deutschen Caritasverbandes
Kolleginnen hier auf dem Panel die
Aufgabe die man uns gegeben hat in fünf
Minuten die hier runter laufen ist alles
andere als banal wir sind als
zivilgesellschaftliche Akteure sehr
daran gewöhnt mit Parteien mit Politik
ins Gespräch zu gehen auf der Grundlage
von konkreten Papieren dann können wir
sagen da fehlt noch das und das ein
solches Papier haben wir nicht und
deswegen neigen wir unter Umständen dazu
unsere Zeit zu überziehen und tun uns
schwer die fünf Minuten zu strukturieren
ich sage Ihnen was ich mir vorgenommen
habe und mit den fünf Minuten
auszukommen ich will als erstes kurz
sagen wer wir sind also damit Sie wissen
was ich so im Gepäck habe wenn ich mit
Erwartungen an ihr Grundsatzprogramm
hier heute eingeladen bin ich möchte
Ihnen dann spiegeln wie wir die Union
wahrnehmen was wir sozusagen
grundsätzlich von ihr erwarten um dann
im letzten Teil kurz zu sagen wie sich
dieses gegenüber von dem was wir
mitbringen und dem was wir erwarten in
konkreteren
Formulierungen niederschlagen sollte die
dann in dem Grundsatzprogramm vermutlich
niedergeschrieben werden wer sind wir
für wen könnte ich hier heute eingeladen
worden sein Sie haben es vielleicht vor
kurzem in der FAZ gelesen auf Seite 1
und dann muss es ja wohl stimmen allein
in den
Pflegeberufen in den Krankenhäusern in
den Pflegeheimen in den Pflegediensten
sind heute 1,7 Millionen Menschen
beschäftigt das sind fünf Prozent der
Beschäftigten in unserem Land die sind
ganz überwiegend in den Einrichtungen
der Wohlfahrtsverbände beschäftigt das
ist ein Teil derer für die ich hier
heute stehe dazu kommen aber auch die
Menschen für die wir diese Arbeit
erbringen all die zahllosen kranken
alten Menschen mit Beeinträchtigungen
die darauf hoffen dass sozialen Dienst
auf morgen noch erbracht werden können
dass wir Menschen finden die diese
Arbeit morgen und übermorgen noch tun
ich spreche auch für die Menschen die
nicht in Gewerkschaften organisiert sind
die wir aber dringend offenkundig
brauchen um die sozialen Dienste um die
sozialen Nöte zu
bearbeiten auch dazu nur eine Zahl in
163.000 Familien in unserem Land sind
nach den Schätzungen den soliden die wir
haben im Augenblick sogenannte
liv-kräfte 24 Stunden Pflegekräfte
beschäftigt sehr häufig nicht
sozialversicherungspflichtig und der
Anteil den diese Arbeit dieser Menschen
an der Arbeit im deutschen Pflegesystem
ausmacht das sind 32 Prozent das heißt
zu den hohen Beschäftigten Zahlen die
ich ihnen anfangs genannt habe kommen
diese Menschen in der schattenö sie die
auch dazu beitragen dass es in unserem
Land warm bleibt und nicht die soziale
Kälte um sich greift und die haben wir
sehr sehr selten im Blick und eine
allerletzte Zahl aus dem großen Spektrum
dessen was ich Ihnen als zahlen hätte
mitbringen können allein in den letzten
drei Jahren seit das
Bundesverfassungsgericht Urteil dazu
geführt hat dass die Suizidhilfe in
Deutschland nicht mehr reguliert ist
haben 600 Menschen Angebote assistierten
Suizids in Anspruch genommen und das
haben sie nicht getan weil sie das Leben
so lustig finden
mit diesen kleinen Eindrücken dazu wofür
ich hier stehe und besten Perspektive
ich mitbringe will ich Ihnen kurz sagen
wie wir die Union wahrnehmen wer sie für
uns ist und
ich habe jetzt keinen Grundsatzprogramm
mitgebracht aus dem Regal dass sie eben
uns immer geniert haben sondern ich habe
diesen dieses Grundsatzprogramm ähnliche
Produkt mitgebracht Wohlstand für alle
Ludwig Erhards Bibel an dem sich die
Union viele Jahre orientiert hat und ich
finde bis heute faszinierend dieses für
alle wir nehmen die Union wahr als eine
Partei die für alle da sein will für alt
und jung für Männer und Frauen für arme
und reiche und das programmatisch weiter
niederzulegen scheint mir eine der
Aufgaben der Zukunft zu sein
[Applaus]
wir nehmen aber auch die Union war als
die Partei des langen Atems
die Union ist die Partei von Helene
Weber Helene Weber ist die einzige
Person die einzige Frau die an der
Erarbeitung von zwei demokratischen
Verfassungen Deutschlands mitgewirkt hat
in der Verfassung gebenden
Nationalversammlung und den
Parlamentarischen Rat sie war eine der
Mütter dieser Parteien
relativ unbekannt viel bekannter Konrad
Adenauer auch so ein Mann der langen
Strecke der war bereits 73 als der
Bundeskanzler wurde und er blieb das
dann 14 Jahre lang
Helmut Kohl Angela Merkel Wolfgang
Schäuble Ursula von der Leyen letztlich
auch Friedrich Merz alles so Menschen
die in der Union dafür stehen dass die
Union eine Partei des langen Atems ist
und ich glaube das sollten Sie auch sich
noch mal vor Augen führen wenn sie sich
an die Arbeit ihres Grundsatzprogramms
machen es zeichnet eine Partei aus
Partei des langen Atems zu sein gerade
wenn die Zeiten schwierig sind wenn die
Aufgaben nicht so schnell zu lösen sind
dann immer wieder weiter zu bohren aber
man bleibt nur lange in der
Verantwortung wenn man auch den Kairos
vom Kronos unterscheiden kann und den
Kairos nutzt und dann wirklich die Dinge
zum Ende bringt zum Abschluss bringt
umsetzt wenn die Stunde da ist und dafür
sind viele viele Probleme im Augenblick
dringend um den Kairos zu erkennen und
um die Fragen zu lösen ich hoffe dass
dass sich im Programm niederschlagen
kann und liefert noch dies nehmen wir
die Union wahr als die Partei der
Wertorientierungen die tatsächlich not
sehen verstehen und handeln kann und
damit nicht einfach losläuft sondern
sehr genau beurteilt was ist wichtig und
was ist weniger wichtig aus welcher
Haltung heraus können wir diese
nachhaltige Politik machen ich habe
meine Zeit überzogen und deswegen lasse
ich die letzten zwei Sachen natürlich
seit natürlich weg sage Ihnen aber in
einem Wort was ich mir erhoffe was Stadt
Wohlstand für alle über den
Programmabschnitt stehen sollte nämlich
Wohlergehen für alle das scheint mir die
Veränderung zu sein die ansteht wir
müssen wegkommen von einem allzu
ökonomistischen Verständnis von
Wohlstand und einem all zu statischen
Verständnis von Wohlstand hin zu einem
dynamischen stärker das gesamte Leben
umfassenden Verständnis von Wohlergehen
das ist global und lokal zu verstehen
das ist sozial und ökonomisch zu
verstehen ich freue mich wenn wir dazu
im Gespräch bleiben
hut ab Eva Maria welskopp DEFA die
tatsächlich so ziemlich in ihrer Zeit
geblieben ist das Wohlergehen in den
Mittelpunkt gestellt hat und jetzt
beschleunigt die Moderatorin Christina
stürmt das Programm ein bisschen Claudia
Pechstein steht bereits die
Olympiasiegerin im Eisschnelllauf
ich halte das grundsätzlich für eine
super Idee wenn sich die Politik die CDU
Entschuldigung für ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm Impulse aus der
cd-gesellschaft erhofft
natürlich stehe ich hier in erster Linie
für den Sport und äh der Sport ist und
unter Zivilgesellschaft natürlich später
eine große Rolle und ich darf mich jetzt
daran versuchen einen Impuls zu setzen
es wird sicherlich es wird sie sicher
nicht überraschen wenn ich anrege
grundsätzlich den breiten Vereins und
Schulsport zu stärken nur wer hier gute
Bedingungen schafft darf darauf hoffen
dass der das auch der Spitzensport davon
profitieren kann
[Musik]
und dabei ist natürlich auch nicht das
Ehrenamt zu vergessen denn ohne Ehrenamt
finden keine Veranstaltung keine
sportlichen Veranstaltungen statt keine
Wettkämpfe auch ich habe davon jahrelang
profitiert und einen ganz ganz
herzlichen Dank auch auf dieser an
dieser Stelle an das Ehrenamt
wir haben hierzulande rund 86.000
Vereine mit mehr als 23 Millionen
Mitgliedern das entspricht etwa 37% der
deutschen Bevölkerung das ist gewaltig
und dennoch gehen die Zahlen rückläufig
der Nachwuchs ist häufig lieber zu Hause
vor der Konsole als sich aktiv zu
bewegen das Problem beginnt schon in der
Schule in die Hände klatschen ein paar
Kniebeuge machen reicht für die Kinder
genauso wenig wie nur eine Stunde Sport
im wöchentlichen Unterricht schon jetzt
haben viele Kids Probleme einen kurze
Baum zu schlagen
das sollte uns alle alarmieren denn
grundsätzlich gilt mangelnde Fitness in
früheren Jahren wird nicht dazu
beitragen später die Gesundheitskassen
zu entlasten
vom mangeln Anreiz für den Spitzensport
ganz zu schweigen ich kann es aus meiner
eigenen jahrelang Erfahrung berichten
dass heute auf weltcupreisen die nächste
Shoppingtour für manche Läuferinnen den
gleichen Anreiz ausübt wie die
Wettkämpfe auf dem Eis und es gab Zeiten
das undenkbar
ich bin ich bin nicht hier um meine
eigenen Leistung zu schmälern aber es
dürfte eigentlich nicht möglich sein
dass eine 51-jährige in einer
olympischen Sportarten noch Deutsche
Meisterin wird bei unseren Nachbarn in
den Niederlanden wäre ich schon längst
in der Rente
um es mit dem Worten von Altkanzler
Helmut Kohl zu sagen Leistung muss ich
wieder lohnen es gibt Nationen da haben
Olympiasieger für ihre spätes Leben
ausgesorgt ich habe fünf Mal olympisches
Gold gewonnen und bin trotzdem weiter
von entfernt da ich da ich in meinem
Alter auch weiter von entfernt bin ein
sechstes Mal Olympiasiegerin zu werden
kann mir niemand Eigennutz unterstellen
wenn ich anrege dass es grundsätzlich
keine schlechte Sache wäre olympisches
Gold nicht nur mit 20.000 Euro zu
entlohnen
[Applaus]
der oder die beste der Welt im Sinne der
olympischen Gedanken zu sein ist mit
großen Entbehrungen Disziplin Willen und
auch mit Qualen verbunden glauben Sie
mir ich weiß wovon ich rede
wenn wir sportlich wieder ganz vorne
mitwischen wollen dann gilt der kölsche
Grundsatz umso mehr damit sich Leistung
wieder lohnt sollten auch die
förderplätze der Bundeswehr und auch bei
der Bundespolizei und da wären wir schon
längst beim nächsten Impuls
grundsätzlich an harte
Leistungskriterien geknüpft und nicht
verschenkt werden
überhaupt scheint es mir so dass derzeit
viel verschenkt und zu wenig entlohnt
wird ich bin selbst jetzt seit
Jahrzehnten Bundespolizisten als
Polizeihauptmeisterin stehe ich mit
meinen Kollegen im regen Austausch und
es ist für uns alle unstrittig dass man
Menschen in Not helfen muss aber wenn
Menschen zu uns kommen und Asyl
beantragen und einen Richter nach
Prüfung aller Fakten zu dem Schluss
kommt dass der Antragsteller kein Recht
hat hier zu leben dann versteht niemand
dass solche Menschen einfach hier
bleiben dürfen
[Applaus]
wenn ich richtig informiert bin reden
wir derzeit etwa über 300.000 solcher
Fälle wir sollten grundsätzlich die
Rahmenbedingungen schaffen um dieses
Problem rechtsstaatlich zu lösen so
erleichtern wir nur nicht nur die Arbeit
der Polizei Kolleginnen sondern auch
grundsätzlich für mehr sicher sorgen
auch grundsätzlich für mich mehr
Sicherheit im Alltag der Menschen allein
die öffentliche rechtlichen
Verkehrsmittel zu nutzen zu können ohne
ängstliche Blicke nach links und rechts
werfen zu müssen gehört zum Beispiel
gehört zu den Alltagsproblemen die viele
besonders ältere Menschen unter Frauen
belasten
darüber wird viel zu wenig gesprochen
meiner Meinung nach hierfür Verbesserung
zu sorgen sollte uns grundsätzlich 100
mal wichtiger sein als darüber
nachzudenken ob wir einen
gender-sternchen setzen oder ob ein
Konzert noch deutscher Liederabend
heißen da
oder ob es noch erlaubt ist ein
Zigeunerschnitzel zu bestellen das sind
Themen die viele Menschen bewegen und in
den familienkopfschütteln diskutiert
werden ich bin selbst ein
ausgesprochener Familienmensch womit wir
auch schon beim nächsten Impuls sind
denn ich den ich als Abschluss setzen
möchte die CDU ist immerhin die Familien
ist tschuldigung die CDU ist immer die
Familienpartei Deutschlands gewesen und
ist es nach wie vor meine Eltern habe
ich haben mich und meine Geschwister mit
viel Liebe zu anständigen Menschen
erzogen eine intakte Familie ist auch
ein Idealbild von dreiviertel der
deutschen
in der shell-studien über die
Zukunftswünsche unserer Kinder stehen
gute Freunde und Familie ganz weit oben
gerade wegen aller gerade wegen aller
Probleme um sie herum die Kinder hier zu
Lande wollen nicht nur einen guten Job
eine heile Familie eine
traditionelle Familie sie wollen Mama
und Papa
die Familienpolitik der christlichen
demokratischen Union sollte sich
grundsätzlich zuallererst mit der
traditionellen Familie beschäftigen weil
wir aufhören die familienparteien im
Lande zu sein dann werden wir auch nicht
mehr Volkspartei in Deutschland sein
Claudia Pechstein die fünfmalige
Olympiasiegerin im Eisschnelllauf mit
einem Plädoyer dafür das traditionelle
Familienbild in den Kern der Betrachtung
zu stellen bei der CDU
[Musik]
und der letzte Impulsgeber in diesem
reiten wird der Vorsitzende der
Initiative Jugendparlament sein und
Podcasts oben Juliano
geben wir sind schon ganz gespannt legen
Sie los
ja also auf jeden Fall erstmal vielen
Dank ist hier eine Menge Power und
Energie drin bin ich aus den letzten
Jahren der CDU gar nicht so gewohnt also
wirklich wirklich toll ja liebe Frau
Sturm lieber Herr Merz Herr Scheyer Herr
Linnemann als ich jetzt vor wenigen
Wochen diesen Anruf von der CDU erhalten
habe und man mich gefragt habe ob ich
nicht ein paar Worte für die junge
Generation sprechen würde musste ich
erstmal zugegebenermaßen breit grinsen
denn ich bin ja eher so dieser
Jugendlicher wie Philipp Amthor der sich
er im Anzug wohl fühlt als ein T-Shirt
und dementsprechend war es aber dann
doch eine Ehre und natürlich bin auch
ich einer dieser vielen Millionen jungen
Menschen die noch vor kurzem ein
Großteil ihrer Freiheit aufgegeben haben
um in der corona-pandemie die ältere
Generation also auch ehrlicherweise
viele von ihnen zu schützen ich
bin
ich bin einer dieser vielen Millionen
jungen Menschen die erstmals wieder
Kriegstreibern bei ihrem Handeln zusehen
müssen und ich bin einer dieser vielen
Millionen jungen Menschen die die Folgen
des Klimawandels wahrscheinlich am
deutlichsten spüren werden die Zeiten
sind schwierig aber die Zeiten waren auf
ihre Art und Weise schon immer schwierig
deswegen lohnt sich das gar nicht noch
weiter diese Jammer ähm Phase weiter zu
machen denn ich glaube diese junge
Generation hat auch so viel Potenzial
und so viele Chancen wie kaum eine
andere junge Generation vorher und ich
glaube gerade die CDU hat das Potenzial
wieder diese junge Generation für sich
zu gewinnen
bei der
bei der vergangenen Bundestagswahl haben
wir erlebt dass vor allem FDP und Grüne
sehr stark abgeschnitten haben gerade
bei den Jungen lediglich zehn Prozent
der jungen Bevölkerung haben die CDU
gewählt und das kann wirklich eine
christliche demokratische Partei die den
Anspruch hat weite Bevölkerungsgruppen
zu erreichen nicht zufriedenstellen
was
was erwarten wir also von einer modernen
CDU die junge Menschen erreicht ich will
das gerne an drei Punkten festmachen
erstens es braucht wieder mehr Vision es
braucht einen German Dream ich meine
heute wird hier viel über Vision
gesprochen und in der Tat es gibt
weiterhin viel Armut in unserem Land
jedes fünfte Kind wächst in Armut auf
und da muss die CDU die Hand ausstrecken
und sagen wir sind an eurer Seite wir
ermöglichen euch dass ihr das erreichen
könnt was ihr wollt dass ihr dahin kommt
wohin ihr wollt dieses Versprechen
Aufstieg durch Leistung Aufstieg durch
Bildung das darf keine Floskel mehr sein
das muss die CDU bedienen als Vision das
muss man Gefühlen
und und zum zweiten möchte ich natürlich
das Thema Klimaschutz erwähnen ich weiß
manche langweilt das manche finden das
mehr interessant manche weniger ich
glaube man kann mittlerweile kein Bogen
mehr drumrum machen das Thema
Klimaschutz das Thema Klimawandel ich
glaube auch jeder nimmt ihn mittlerweile
ab der sieht zumindest ernst nimmt dass
sie das Thema Klimaschutz ernst nehmen
dass sie das fühlen aber dennoch fehlt
da bei weitem Teilen ich nehme da auch
an die Jungen etwas außen vor der hat
dann eine große Leidenschaft aber ich
muss sagen weite Teile der Partei da
fehlt noch die Leidenschaft das
Klimaschutz nicht ein Nischenthema ist
nicht ein Thema das am Rande bedient
wird sondern dass es wirklich ein Thema
ist wo wir Leidenschaft brauchen denn
ohne Klimaschutz wird es dann auch wenig
andere Politik zu machen geben also da
würde ich mir wünschen dass man das
Thema wird mehr Leidenschaft anpackt mit
mehr Begeisterung
und
zum dritten ich sehe die die Zeit rennt
mir davon deswegen fühlt sich das gerne
etwas ab damit wir auch hier weiter
inhaltlich diskutieren können ich freue
mich sehr zum dritten wir haben jetzt in
den vergangenen Wochen Zahlen erlebt
beispielsweise dieses Umfrage hoch der
AFD 18 19% möglicherweise bei der
nächsten Bundestagswahl
das hat natürlich viele Gründe und sie
sagen auch zu Recht die Ampel ist daran
schuld ja aber nicht nur weil was
bedeutet das wenn so viele sich
vorstellen können diese AFD zu wählen
dann bedeutet das aber auch dass sie in
der CDU nicht mehr die richtige
Alternative sehen und da ist deswegen
ist auch dieser grundsatzkonvent so
wichtig dass man diese inhaltlichen
Nuancen endlich wieder spürt dass man
versteht was ist der Unterschied
zwischen der Ampel und der Union und das
man dann möglicherweise auch in Zukunft
nicht mehr so oft auf ich gebe zu
populistische Parolen ab und zu
zurückgreifen muss sondern sich
lediglich auf sein Programm fokussieren
kann und sagen das ist die Union das ist
die Ampel und dann erreichen sie nämlich
auch wieder die Jugend dann erreichen
Sie die jungen Menschen die erreichen
sind nicht wirklich wenn sie
populistische Parolen oder so raushauen
sondern die erreichen Sie wenn Sie
überzeugt sich hinstellen und sagen das
wollen wir das wollen wir erreichen und
wir wollen nicht nur die Ampel sein und
deswegen lassen Sie mich
lassen Sie mich
lassen sie mich zum Schluss gerne noch
ein Gedanken formulieren sie als CDU
sind eine alte Partei sie haben viel
regiert die letzten 16 Jahre die Ampel
sagt sie ja hoch und runter
aber ich glaube wir müssen auch
konstatieren die Streitkultur in
Deutschland das belastet und auch die
Demokratie ist belastet immer mehr
scheinen sich abzuwenden immer mehr
scheinen sich von dieser Demokratie
verabschieden zu wollen ich bin
Vorsitzender der Initiative
Jugendparlament einem Verein das gerade
junge Menschen begeistern will sich an
der Demokratie zu beteiligen und ich
freue mich auch sehr dass wir viele
unterstützen haben auch aus ihrer Partei
ich will namentlich Frau Güter nennen
die bei uns im Beirat sitzt aber auch
Herr grammling Herr Tessmann aus ähm
Land Sachsen-Anhalt oder aus
Baden-Württemberg Andreas Sturm also wir
wollen wirklich wieder Begeisterung
schaffen für die Demokratie für junge
Menschen und diesen Weg wollen wir auch
gemeinsam mit ihm gehen und deswegen
freue ich mich wenn wir zusammen für
mehr Demokratie begeistert
Ruben Giuliano war das der Vorsitzende
der Initiative Jugendparlament mit drei
wünschen die er formuliert hat an die
CDU und für das neue Grundsatzprogramm
erstens eine Vision einen German Dream
für Deutschland zweitens einen
ernsthafteren Umgang mit dem Thema
Klimaschutz und drittens eine deutliche
Profilierung eine Abgrenzung auch von
den anderen Parteien damit es dann in
der Zukunft auch wieder möglich ist
jüngere Wählerinnen und Wähler zu
gewinnen damit in Zukunft die nicht
weiter nur zur FDP und zu den Grünen
gehen Ruben Giuliano hat gesagt er hat
so viel Energie wie hier bei diesem
Grundsatz Konvent lange nicht mehr
gespürt und die Frage gebe ich weiter an
meinen Kollegen die hat Joachim von
verloren viel Energie heute im Raum
ja natürlich ist viel Energie im Raum
der vor allen Dingen sind es Menschen
die nicht der CDU angehören die hier
Impulsreferate gehalten haben nachher
gibt es ja noch zehn Fachkommissionen
die hier miteinander diskutieren und er
weitere Ergebnisse erarbeiten werden wir
werden gleich zu den Bündnisgrünen rüber
schalten die heute ihren kleinen
Parteitag haben ich hatte das für 11 Uhr
angekündigt meine Damen und Herren da
verschiebt sich der Anfang ein wenig
deswegen habe ich noch die Gelegenheit
hier bei der CDU mit der
Politikwissenschaftlerin Julia
Reuschenbach zu sprechen Frau
Reichenbach wir haben jetzt hier diese
Impuls Referate gehört gerade der junge
Mann hat doch ganz imposante Dinge hier
vorgetragen wie man wieder CDU wählen
könnte seine Meinung
eine junge Stimme eine Stimme oder
Stimmen die in der CDU nicht so oft zu
hören sind wo das Wählerpotenzial
schwierig ist wo man nicht hat
überzeugen können insbesondere bei der
letzten Bundestagswahl wir haben hier
zwei große Forderungen würde ich mal
herausgreifen gehört nämlich zum einen
den Hinweis darauf dass Klimaschutz
wirklich ein zentrales Anliegen auch der
CDU sein muss weil ansonsten auch in
vielen anderen Politikfeldern die
Handlungsspielräume enger werden weil
man Visionen Ideen nicht umsetzen kann
wenn sie sozusagen unter mangelnder
Transformation leiden und dann gab es
auch anknüpfend an die parteiinterne
Debatte der letzten Tage auch den
Hinweis darauf dass rechtspopulistische
Sprache ein Anti ampelkurs alleine nicht
überzeugen können sondern dass das
gefordert wird von jungen Menschen zu
sagen wir wollen Inhalte wir wollen
Programmatik wir wollen wissen wofür ihr
steht das muss der Kurs sein und nicht
einfach nur zusammen sind dagegen oder
die Ampel macht es gut diese Diskussion
mit der rechtspopulistischen Sprache da
möchte ich noch mal nachhaken also der
Vergleich oder die Aussage von Herrn
Merz mit dem Pascha das war vielleicht
unglücklich der ein oder andere mag das
kritisieren aber treibt das wirklich
Menschen dazu jetzt eher AFD zu wählen
als die CDU es ist natürlich nicht eine
Äußerung alleine in einer Fernsehsendung
wir wissen alle die politische Debatten
sind impulsiv sind emotional da darf
auch mal eine Äußerung irgendwie ein
bisschen zu weit geraten aber es ist die
Gesamtheit der Äußerung wenn sie sich
mal Zitate aus den vergangenen Wochen
von Mitgliedern von auch führenden
Christdemokraten anschauen da wurde
gewettet gegen eine grüne meinungselite
Markus Söder der von der CSU man ist ja
nun mal auch eine Fraktion zu
parteigemeinschaft sagte etwas von einer
zwanghaften veganisierung die in
Deutschland stattfindet Friedrich Merz
hat gesagt Jenner gerechte Sprache würde
der AFD jede Woche in den Medien würde
jede Woche hunderte Stimmen zu AFD
bringen und die Gesamtheit dieser
Sprachbilder ist tatsächlich da ist sich
die Forschung einig geeignet im Grunde
rechtspopulistische Sprache salonfähig
zu machen trägt sie in die Mitte des
demokratischen Diskurses und wir sehen
das etwa unter anderem darin dass wir
inzwischen 27 Prozent Menschen haben in
Deutschland die sagen die AFD ist und
das obwohl es rechtsextreme Einstufungen
gibt etwa durch den Verfassungsschutz
die sagen die AFD ist eine normale
Partei wie jede andere auch also wir
sehen
normalisierungseffekte einerseits und
andererseits sehen wir tatsächlich auch
und dazu gibt es viele Daten auch zu den
Landtagswahlen wenn sie mal an die
letzte bayerische Landtagswahl etwa
denken dass tatsächlich solche Sprache
geeignet ist am Ende Stimmen zum
Original zu bringen und womöglich für
die CDU zumindest auch dazu führen
können dass man in der politischen Mitte
Stimmen verliert dort wo man potentiell
mit grünen mit FDP und SPD um
Wählerinnen und Wähler konkuriert das
ist eine interessanter einer Lyse denn
wenn man die Menschen fragt die gewillt
sind AFD zu wählen dann sagen sie als
allererstes Thema es gibt so viele
Asylanten in Deutschland das muss
abgestellt werden als zweites Thema
sagen Sie diese gender Sprache dieses
nicht mehr normal reden wie wir Menschen
das macht es aus wegen ich dann bei der
AFD Kreuze und ist derjenige wie
Friedrich Merz der das in einem der das
anspricht ist derjenige der die Menschen
zur AFD treibt oder sind es nicht die
Menschen die in der Tat mit ihrem
Glauben gegen den Duden zum Beispiel zu
Gendern zu müssen das sind ja überhaupt
wenig Menschen teilweise sitzen sie in
der Regierung nämlich mit den Grünen z.B
ist das nicht tatsächlich eine Ursachen
Umkehr die Leute sind einfach genervt
davon und wenn das jemand anspricht ist
er doch nicht derjenige der die Menschen
zur AFD treiben da müssen wir jetzt eine
ganze Menge noch mal auseinander basteln
also erstens ich glaube etwas Ansprechen
im politischen Diskurs ist überhaupt
nicht das was hier in in Zweifel steht
im Gegenteil hat in der Sache
verbindlich im Ton ist sicherlich das
was die politische Debatte immer
brauchen kann und natürlich mussten
Oppositionspartei zumal die führende
Oppositionskraft auch Kritik üben können
an der Ampel und an ihrem Kurs zweitens
aber im Grunde noch mal an die Daten die
sie bemüht haben wenn wir uns einfach
die Ergebnisse wir haben jetzt in
Deutschlands Trend der
deutschland-trends anschauen dann ist es
gerade zum Beispiel nicht gendergerechte
Sprache die die AFD Wählerinnen und
Wähler bewegt das ist Migration da gebe
ich Ihnen völlig recht das ist immer
noch das Thema mit dem die AFD mit
großem Abstand am stärksten mobilisieren
kann wir wissen aus der Forschung zur
Partei dass weite Teile der
afd-anhängerschaft insbesondere der
stammwählerinnen und Stammwähler
gefestigt migrationsfeindliche
Einstellung unterhält also da trifft man
sich auch in gemeinsamen Überzeugungen
und an zweiter Stelle steht inzwischen
Energie und Klima das ist etwas was wir
im den Debatten um das Gebäude
Energiegesetz gesehen haben ein bisschen
Robert habe und die Grünen wirklich zum
neuen Feindbild stilisiert was wir aus
den Reihen der AFD immer wieder hören
und gender gerechte Sprache liegt mit
gerade mal 10% der Nennung wirklich weit
weit abgeschlagen insofern muss man
schon die Frage stellen ob gerade aus
Sicht der Union dass die Themen sind die
man groß machen will ist dass das wo man
auch programmatisch liefern will oder
eröffnet man damit womöglich nicht sogar
Tür und Tor die Frage inwiefern CDU und
AFD nicht doch auch in bestimmten
Feldern im gemeinsamen Positionen Teilen
ich glaube tatsächlich die großen
Antworten auf andere Fragen Inflation
Wohnungsbau soziale Gerechtigkeitsfragen
wie sichere Arbeitsplätze Rente das sind
die Fragen wo eine Partei wie die CDU
wieder Antworten liefern muss und wo Sie
auch zurück kann zu etwas wo sie immer
noch im Vergleich zu allen anderen
Parteien die stärksten kompetenzwerte
erzielen kann nämlich
Stabilitätsanker zu sein genau diese
Themen werden ja bearbeitet heute auch
hier in weiteren Arbeitsgruppen wir
wollen uns gerade mal den Vorsitzenden
Anhören des Gesamtprozesses ist nämlich
den stellvertretenden Parteivorsitzenden
Carsten Linnemann den ich hier vorhin
vor diesen Kongress interviewen konnte
die CDU war noch nie eine klassische
programmpartei warum jetzt ein neues
Grundsatzprogramm Zeiten haben sich
völlig geändert zum einen regieren wir
nicht mehr wir haben die Wahl verloren
weil wir nicht mehr gut genug waren auch
innerlich das müssen wir jetzt
korrigieren und zum anderen
die Menschen sind doch völlig
überfordert ob der Globalisierung und
der Komplexität dieser Welt die brauchen
doch Halt und Orientierung keiner weiß
noch mehr wo geht es überhaupt hin was
ist unser Ziel was ist unsere Vision und
dieses braucht dieses Land wieder und
das wollen wir dem Land geben ist dieses
Programm mehr für die Bürger die die CDU
wählen sollen oder doch nicht mehr für
die CDU selber die im Moment ja so ein
bisschen zerrissen scheint zwischen
denen die dem alten Merkel kurz treu
bleiben wollen und denen die sagen wir
brauchen mehr konservative Elemente ich
kann das mit diesen ganzen Kurs nicht
mehr hören jeder der weiß die CDU hat
einen Fundament wir gehen vom C aus das
christliche Menschenbild ist unser
Fundament wir machen nicht Politik gegen
die Menschen sondern mit den Menschen
und wir sagen nicht den Menschen wie sie
zu leben haben sondern wir lassen sie
leben und das ist unser Ziel und darauf
daran richten wir alles aus und das ist
wenn Sie so wollen eine bürgerliche
Politik
die Menschen wollen dass der Rechtsstaat
funktioniert dass wir sicher leben dass
wir eine Bildung haben die uns hilft
dass das Geld sicher ist und die Zukunft
der Kinder abgesichert ist Stichwort
Klima und Schulden das sind Themen und
diese ganzen Scheindebatten ob man
irgendwelche bestimmten Begriffe ob man
Pascha sagen darf oder nicht da werde
ich in meinem Wahlkreis nicht drauf
angesprochen sondern die Menschen sagen
kümmert euch um das dahinter stehende
Problem dass die Integration hier und da
fehl läuft wie wollt ihr das Bewältigen
darum geht diese scheinde Button hier in
Berlin die gehen mir manchmal wirklich
gegen den Strich wir müssen uns ja um
die wahren Probleme vor Ort kümmern und
vor allen Dingen darum kümmern dass die
CDU erkennbar ist ich vereinfache
wirklich die Grünen stehen für Umwelt
die SPD für Soziales und viele fragen
sich immer wofür steht die konservative
christlich demokratische Union
sie wollen am Schluss glaube ich zwei
Seiten aufsetzen wie soll das aussehen
ich möchte dass die CDU zum Beispiel mit
dem Thema leisten in Verbindung gebracht
wird fordern und fördern gibt es ja in
meisten Fällen in diesem Lande ja gar
nicht mehr derjenige der sich für die
Flüchtlingshilfe einsetzt der vielleicht
e-jugendtrainer ist vor Ort der arbeiten
geht oder gearbeitet hat und jetzt die
Rente genießt das sind doch Menschen die
Mittelpunkt stehen müssen die Leisten
und dieses fordern und fördern ist in
Deutschland völlig abhanden gekommen und
deshalb müssen wir uns um die Menschen
kümmern bei 45 Jahre gearbeitet hat muss
mehr als derjenige nicht gearbeitet hat
warum sagen man nicht bei der Rente wird
das Rentenalter erreicht und freiwillig
länger arbeiten will kann das steuerfrei
machen bis zu einem bestimmten Betrag wo
ist denn das Problem und auf der anderen
Seite finde ich kann man auch erwarten
dass wenn jemand die Solidargemeinschaft
den Anspruch nimmt
auch wenn er den Arbeiten kann also
körperlich und psychisch in der Lage ist
auch Arbeit annehmen muss das ist in den
Niederlanden normal das ist in Dänemark
normal und das sollte auch bei uns
normal sein das sind für mich
bürgerliche Werte und dafür muss die CDU
widerstehen
ganz kurz auf vier Begriffe gebracht was
ist CDU warum sollte man CDU wählen
einfach mal machen die CDU will ein Bild
malen dass die Menschen einfach mal
machen können es ist doch absurd du bist
wie ersticken doch in Bürokratie und
Überregulierung wenn da einer eine Idee
hat der kann doch gar nicht mehr
loslaufen da kommt doch sofort die
Bedenkenträger und einfach mal ein Klima
schaffen das für Aufbruch und Erneuerung
steht und den Menschen mal das Leben
ermöglicht und nicht den vorschreibt wie
sie zu leben haben zu essen haben zu was
auch immer das wäre meine Vision vielen
Dank
der Chef der grundsatzkommission ja
einfach mal machen hat er empfohlen wie
ersticken in Bürokratie das ist
sicherlich kein Problem der aktuellen
Ampel alleine da hat natürlich die
Vorgängerregierung unter der CDU genauso
dran Anteil aber was er natürlich damit
meint ist diese völlige Überregulierung
in Deutschland es geht ja hin bis zu der
Frage von Bau von Windkraft Rädern der
Bundeskanzler sagt immer die neue
Geschwindigkeit nur weil wir ein
paradoxter
verankert haben in der Tat in
Deutschland geht alles viel zu langsam
wie kann man das denn auflösen
naja ob die Politikwissenschaft darauf
die perfekten Antworten hat würde ich
auch noch mal ein Zweifel stellen wollen
aber ich glaube entscheidend ist dass
man erkannt hat dass die
Schnelllebigkeit die Krisenhaftigkeit
die Intensität der Herausforderung in
den letzten Jahren so stark zugenommen
hat dass man sich nicht mehr alleine
vielleicht ein Stück weit auch
zurückziehen kann auf Deutsch
Gründlichkeit für die man sich früher
selbst geschätzt und für die man auch
international sehr geschätzt wurde dass
eben die Dinge doch ihre Zeit haben
sollen und dann auch belastbar und
gründlich rauskommen sondern dass es
hier und da mehr Dynamik braucht und
Dynamik heißt natürlich auch die
Anforderungen an Offenheit heißt
Anforderungen an Fehlertoleranz also
womöglich nicht alles perfekt machen zu
können aber um es mit Carsten Linnemann
zu sagen zu machen insofern glaube ich
ist es wichtig dass eine Partei wie die
CDU sie haben die Mitverantwortung
angesprochen wenn wir etwas mal an die
ressour Verantwortung denken die sind in
der großen Koalition unter der Union gab
dass man sich dem auch kritisch stellt
dass man sagt wo sind Dinge auch
unzureichend gelaufen wo haben wir nicht
genug Dynamik nicht genug sozusagen
Entfesselung den Begriff auch noch mal
zu bemühen hergestellt um Bürokratie
abzubauen um Gesellschaft zu stärken und
Prozesse zu beschleunigen und ich bin
sehr gespannt inwiefern ist eben gelingt
und das ist glaube ich die eigentliche
Herausforderung solche ich nenne es dann
doch mal ein eher allgemein Platz wie
den von Carsten Linnemann jetzt in
seiner Rede wirklich programmatisch in
konkrete Forderungen zu überführen denn
es ist ja allen Parteien gemeinsam dass
sie bürokratieabberufen und die
entscheidende Frage ist natürlich wie
will man es machen und darauf wollen
Wählerinnen und Wähler wollen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger Antworten haben
in dieser grundsatzkommission
mitarbeiten können denn das ist ja genau
das was Carsten Linnemann auch schon mal
ausgeführt hat was er erreichen will in
einem Jahr soll der Prozess
abgeschlossen sein dann im Mai beim
Parteitag verabschiedet werden ein
Grundsatzprogramm ist eine Versicherung
wo man steht das braucht die CDU gerade
nach den letzten Jahren aber natürlich
genauso wichtig sind die Köpfe was
glauben Sie was wird entscheidend sein
für die nächsten anderthalb Jahre für
die CD also sicherlich geht es nicht nur
darum rauszufinden wo man steht sondern
es geht vor allen Dingen auch
diesem Punkt darum rauszufinden welche
Antworten man für die Zukunft
formulieren will ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig dass dieses Grundsatzprogramm
eben nicht im jetzt verharzt sondern
wirklich nach vorne schaut und damit im
Grunde auch eine Antwort auf ihre zweite
Frage liefert nämlich wer sind wir
welche Personen prägen uns wie gelingt
es uns unterschiedliche Strömungen in
der Partei zusammenzubringen und da
haben wir diese Woche im Grunde passend
auf diesen Grundsatz Konvent zulaufen ja
erlebt es gibt die unterschiedlichen
Positionen in der Partei es gibt die die
sagen wir müssen uns breiter aufstellen
wir müssen andere Wählergruppen an oder
neue mehr Wählergruppen adressiert wie
wir dürfen Frauen nicht vergessen die
man unter Angela Merkel unter anderem
stark als WählerInnen gewinnen konnte
und es gibt die anderen die eben einen
doch einen rigidieren ein
konservativeren Kurs fordern und das
zusammenzubringen das scheint mir die
Aufgabe zu sein und zwar nicht nur
personell in Geschlossenheit innerhalb
der Partei sondern wirklich auch das
programmatisch tatsächlich in diesem
Grundsatzprogramm ganz konkret
abzubildenberg
Politikwissenschaftlerin vom Otto so
Institut vielen Dank für ihre Analysen
meine Damen und Herren die CDU will sich
vergewissern wo sie steht sie braucht
programmatisch eine neue Grundlage die
Grünen die brauchen auch eine Klärung
und zwar ganz dringend bei der Frage
Asylpolitik zum Beispiel haben sich die
heute getroffen in Bad Vilbel in Hessen
und da erwarten jetzt einen kleinen
Länder ein Ländereien einen kleinen
Parteitag und für uns ist vor Ort
Jeanette Clark die durch diesen länderat
führen wird bitte
[Musik]
ja herzlich willkommen aus Hessen hier
aus Bad Vilbel tatsächlich die Grünen
werden sich heute treffen zu diesem
Grünen